foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
Lord what's going on
talk to the people right quick a little
under the weather today strolling in
gotta figure it out but I'm gonna get
myself together how y'all doing what's
up Ponte what's going on
lydian Master what's going on primed and
ready let's get after it IOP yes sir yes
sir caboose in the building Christopher
Hart what's up I see you you know what
I'm saying
protocol okay
Boosie the clown what's going on IMAX
what's going on salute salute salute
dead proof what up what up yeah what's
going on what's going on what's up north
Metro to the building first bristle yeah
[ __ ] chocolate mango I see you acting
about your man yes sir yes sir excuse my
voice I'm a little under the weather but
we gonna try to power through New York
got a little cold again no rainy again
[Music]
well let's see who's late everybody's
late the only person I spoke to is King
King is um getting up out of bed
build that eat some chicken soup
if it lasts like another another dance
[Music]
in New York we got extreme temperature
dips New York New Jersey Tri-State
extreme temperature dip so we could be
like 70 80 and then the next day boom 30
40 and when the when the temperature
dips like that that's when I get sick
you know so it's more like a sinus thing
anyway God so what's up what's going on
it kill the chickens for sale
yeah get those get those get that soup
so we can get the rest of the Lords up
here one time and get a good show
popping I like the topics that we got
going on I'm excited
I don't know if y'all caught that um
at a dragon day's trailer just dropped
before ILP oh Metro you in New England
yeah yeah you know what it is you know
what it is with that weather weather
shifts man I can feel a consistent
climate but for a Grizzle what up what's
going on James Morrison what up but uh
yeah we're gonna get people in here all
right to heatless Weatherby has been a
while good to see you bro good to see
you you already know plus we gotta hit
live Supremacy
I got him out of bed Steve go go Dragon
Age four drops
yeah I did Inquisition so if you beat
Inquisition this trailer gonna hit hard
this trailer go ahead hard slow mo get
the eyeballs up now see that okay slow
okay
so join us to Dad Oregon snowing oh it's
snowing by y'all okay
yeah we ain't get the snow yet but yeah
The Season's all over the place man
we'll see what it is but anyway let me
get some people up in here rattle the
cages get the trumpets blow the horns
it's the Lord's day you know what we do
dread Pro okay you from all right yeah I
need jacket for the [ __ ] yeah I got to
be about I feel you I just feel like I
don't know if you caught Mark Dara from
BioWare you know we had a more defining
Duke before one of the OG's and uh he
seemed excited he seemed extremely
confident we've been talking to him
behind the scene like he feel like
Dragon Age is coming I will say that
trailer hit hard and for those who beat
Dragon Age Inquisition Y'all Gonna know
what it is it's dread wolf seasoning
they talking that I'm excited because
there's a lot of detention with that
situation let's just say that but they
kind of blew it up in the trailer for
those who didn't know anyway so yeah it
was crazy it's crazy but anyway
Auntie you don't know say insane
anyway I got to get people in here
so I was talking y'all and see y'all in
the morning black conflict acts let's go
let's go power to the people
yeah
I'll see y'all in a minute hold on Abby
did you use cold Lord 15 or to check out
for that Volari gaming pillow get avoid
game a lean did you do the right thing
all right I really gotta go
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable why can't
it be and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still bicultural I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Fred and Kruger that's oh
let's do that again
[Music]
radio
a problem
[Music]
I'ma just chill and watch them and he
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they will mistake me for addict
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to an
ebender I gotta be me though I know it's
my destiny word to kind needle who cares
if you fly if you stealing mosquito you
swear you ain't nothing but really be
Stevo you like to collect stuff and
that's cool but I got bad news even if
he really was that dude can never still
be the king of the statue since the
juvenile I've been cursed with a curse
to be Musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in The Crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord day
[Music]
that's it like hot bike check my check
and all of that goodness all right
somebody somebody do a little check
right quick
my camera's off
okay everybody's cameras Oh foot by
default I don't know what's good no no
because I'm sitting this snacking
oh you trying to sneak some fools okay
okay see what it is all right and we are
live here ye hear ye welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 283.
it's another Glory Sunday we're back at
the round table on the Lord's day and
today we've got God Howard's last
interview
Kalisto protocol Impressions
you're killing me right
we got series X wins Black Friday
those original gaming Knights the rum
here at the round table my co-host
Nicole most my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord addict of the
attic show how are you doing sir doing
pretty good uh you know trying to trying
to stay awake you know right I actually
got an energy drink for once I don't
normally do energy drinks because I hope
it's not Advanced GG or we need to send
you that shipment using yeah
oh that's that stats violation of the
followers
that's a clear Man actually you need to
hit him with my DMs you hit me sir we
will take care of that yes we got to get
you that Spartacus
exactly all that you talking right there
that's a bad body placement so Advanced
GG ain't just next door and I can walk
over casually
it's quite delicious Titan
which you've been playing sir
uh cholesterol protocol playing some
midnight Sons
I think I'm dropping midnight so yeah I
didn't get the vibe that she was built
in five minutes wait a minute I just saw
a tweet that was very positive you know
how he doing that he played another hour
then it's fine you know I I didn't even
really play after I'm just not feeling
the card system I'm just not failing it
like like it's just like you mean to
tell me I have to have a car to shoot
Iron Man's uh cannons like yeah I just
you know I'm glad people like it but you
know I'll probably eventually beat it
when I'm bored enough but it's just like
I like the the implemented certain
things from like the x-com franchise on
here but like when I'm playing I can't
help but think like I would have
preferred an x-com over this Alexis oh
okay I got you I got you what else
you've been playing
uh cholesterol protocol I'm about five
six hours in I think I think I'm close
to beating it probably in the middle of
the game okay something like that uh no
doubt no I got a lot to say about that
you're pretty hot on Twitter right now
um I'm calling you Lord addictive of
attic timings it's all these glorious
photos of you running around and looking
like you to Mona Lisa another one look
like you've done conquered two castles
something like like he's a new character
and pentiment yeah
a lot of people I I because like when
you do it you actually have to um
go into this you you have to go into the
settings and actually get like a full
blown uh you know they give you a bunch
it's not I just posted two of them
there's that there's 50 of them on top
of those too
it's kind of crazy like like they could
that app can make you look like a
different person like it's it's what's
funny is like
I had one that like had my beard down to
here yeah
it's it's yeah the Merlin joint
s it's it really is it's insane I really
recommend people doing it now you could
do the editing yourself or you can uh
pay them like three bucks to for them to
do how much of our digital rights and uh
so we have to sell to do this app
um
what cryptocurrency yeah how much of a
location you got to give up
um so they do have a uh
uh it is like 30 a year uh but they give
you seven days uh trial okay so I've
already canceled the trial okay so
there's a trial they'd be like yo you
get the credit card and then well they
you can use PayPal
um they the actual
the the they the program for them to do
it like they call it magical avatars
yeah it's like four bucks got it got it
uh and they'll do 50 pictures oh that's
what's up that's what's up so yeah it I
can't imagine the amount of money they
make like I I can't imagine the amount
of money made it must have been
legendary uh but you know it's cool
because I think it's one of those things
where it's interesting enough for you
know let me try it you know what I'm
saying all right no doubt here go check
them out it's all you gotta bump on
Twitter right on your on your profile
did you change your profile you just put
them up no I changed my profile
but I did change is the one that looked
the most like me there's some that I
don't look anything like I actually look
like like that sir like it it's like
they they have one where literally I've
had my beard long before but not this
long like it it was literally down to
like here that's great you should put it
you should put a bump you should share a
screenshot of it while I'm doing the
other intro so people can see what we
talk about yeah we don't well I don't uh
because my camera's been giving me
issues here lately like as far as
focusing so I think I have to like
change some of the settings but what I
could do
I have to
yes
because he belongs in a plague tale
look how long my beard is it's
ridiculous like my beard has never been
that long introducing it was funny it's
like I can get a picture you finding the
Louvre or something like that okay like
some of them look more realistic than
others
go back to Sir addict of addicted can
you please pass me the gray Poupon
there's still more he looks like a
Jasper right there
you look bad different with that yeah
somebody says sober Thorn yo they stupid
yes that's the choice like you'll tell
me that ain't in the the you know what
I'm saying that's like next to the Mona
Lisa that's something that's a surreal
to lose
we got the monk we got the Abbott said
he was known for his brutality yeah
that's just a different Generations
[Laughter]
the taxes of that generation yo what is
going on Fury yo he looking like the
dude that buddy from Halo Infinity
yo you can't last the attic in space
and of course we have a most technical
gaming Lord the solo game who lives with
a single player selfish experience and
also the Nostradamus the Lord of clarity
and Lord patreon of the iron bake my man
Lord Sovereign how we doing how you
feeling I'm doing good man doing good
you know last week I set out to dip out
a little bit earlier for for nephew's
birthday he was very happy you know it's
a you know Pokemon yeah oh yeah he had
the switch already it was the Pokemon
right but you know he he doesn't care
about all the all the the talk about the
the frame rate in the department none of
that matters to him he got his Pokemon
he was good he didn't care about any of
the Pokemons he was good yeah yeah he
was good he was good no that game sold
like 10 million in 30 days or so you see
that's the thing bad we're the problem
this is the
no I mean because you know people come I
don't
the team who's the team behind Pokemon
again what are they called like freak
yeah game free game freak yes game free
call Game Freak yeah you didn't know
that I didn't even know that the
original name didn't fly from yeah it
was Nintendo let that rock
they don't own them they don't own them
yeah
Nintendo doesn't own Pokemon they just
own a stalking
they let that fly okay they haven't they
can't say anything about freaky freaks
because I actually I was curious how the
Pokemon stuff went so I talked to
someone that that's real up to date on
this situation yeah they say no that's
all game free like game freak dictates
everything everything like Netflix not
Netflix Nintendo doesn't really like
they have a little bit of say in it a
little bit of influence but it's not a
lot like they really don't have a lot of
trouble
yeah sit down 10 million sit down yeah
they've said it like though they like
keeping their team smoked we were like
yo why don't you you know bulk up your
team and like you know yeah get some of
these quality control issues under
control nah nah we good bro we good with
low effort and high high Revenue yeah
High Revenue
shout out to Game Freak yeah
so yeah this week uh not not a whole lot
of gaming um this week was anniversary
weeks
yeah it went out to Wifey yesterday we
were up by you a king a little further
Mamaroneck oh no he's way up there bye
yeah a little higher
so it was cool a good time game wise
though
play some more evil West loving it
loving it okay except that that 360
energy was very good like very just you
don't know no huge open world none of
this it's just point A to B get you get
your killing on kill your vampires I
love that
um and it's exactly the the tweaks
they've made since packs are evident are
definitely evident so I'm very happy
with it um Callisto okay I'm liking
parts of it I see people's frustrations
that PC version Oh God okay save some
more save some bars yeah there's a patch
that came out this morning that oh oh
wow okay yeah okay better
um but we'll talk about it
um that's pretty much it no God of War
I'm trying to get back to boy and it
ain't happening
what's the matter exclusively moving you
it's just you know no time to be in
front of the TV I know you want
different experiences
where did you get your data first yeah
okay where's the Platinum rate on this
game yeah
I mean I'll show you I'll show you
what's been going on in these streets
for real
this is what happens after Black Friday
success yo don't do oh man get your
PlayStation
I saw that okay okay
I saw that well the picture before it is
just the warehouse full of God of War uh
Edition PS5 and then then it goes to
that so that's Cyber Monday
God of War it was a fun good game but
people definitely over exaggerated that
I heard so if I was on the um world of
gaming podcast making my monthly ghastly
appearance once in a while
um shout out to uh boxing burger and
wondering Dutch he so Dutch said there's
a whole secret ending at it so
apparently there's like some other
mission that you got to do yeah yeah oh
you did I didn't know yeah I'll be a
member of 10 too
I'm trying to link it to PlayStation
Plus
I feel like it definitely
deserves to be a nomination of game of
the year but I don't think it even
touches out
you did the secret ending
yeah it I mean it's not a secret ending
it's like a post ending like after you
beat the last boss you have to do
certain things to get a post ending but
it's just like that didn't really do
anything like a mission though it's not
a mission prior like you got to decide
something that happens in the game and
the results of that you dress after the
game got it okay got it uh so I mean it
it it's cool but it's just like the
thing is
God of War
didn't do anything drastically different
from 18 and I feel like what's going to
hurt it the most is when elder and Rain
came out I feel like that was that was a
movement everyone was talking about it
and I'm not saying no one was talking
about God of War right but I feel like
it's already fizzing out it was still
hot on Eldon rink first
like three months
for three months that's all I saw was
out like everywhere Twitter Tick Tock
and YouTube yeah no YouTube video after
YouTube video yeah I mean I was being
told by big YouTubers not to make a
haunted that's not Elden ring that's how
bad it was true the algorithm was was
crazy too if you it kept going yeah yeah
old ladies playing ain't nobody playing
this God of War anyway so that's been
it's uh
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the excess gamer ooh
the prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
doing a whole lot better than last week
oh my God and I'm doing way better than
uh PlayStation's fake Cyber Monday
Victory you know this is out here for
Cyber Monday yo we had a Resurgence on
Cyber Monday
we're still alive oh man I noticed Black
Friday talk gonna be very interesting to
you
spicy
so I saw a little uh Series S out in
Times Square getting sturdy he was out
there
everybody wanted you know see what's
going on with the kid
um
what I've been playing this week this
has been a crazy week yeah vampire
survival a true secret boss
is
true secrets and hidden things
so I found I found this little um I
don't know like it's it's weird it's
like you're a giant brain but with a man
out of it like a centaur get out of it
shooting lasers or whatever
um he's one of the new guys that I got
out so I'm playing that and I'm thinking
oh man this is gonna go crazy but then
fortnite jumped in wear this ugly head
uh what monkey we was trying to get him
leveled up as much as possible to finish
his uh battle pass right he became a
member okay so me him Galveston uh j-rex
and we getting chicken dinner something
crazy we acting up we're acting we're
literally mobbing across the board
exactly
four Killers
um fantastic stuff man I feel really
happy for monkey getting his niches oh
so this is him finally getting back like
messing with you on fortnite yeah he's
like no build mode we out here acting oh
so he just now learning about the Nobel
attic tell him that I heard that before
they about to do something crazy
so they blew up the map what they do
they blew up the map again again yeah
yeah and some reason they had looking at
the screen like they had the Hulk in the
promo for the next season
people could say what they want but they
will never be a game like fortnite ever
again like it it is like I used to think
that Call of Duty was the game that made
gaming more mainstream than anything
else no that is fortnite now
like nothing touches it like you could
the only thing that would even come
remotely close is Minecraft
after Minecraft it's like my crafting
fortnite's way up here and everything
else is way down it's like merged pop
culture anything that's popping
everything finds a way in foreign
they got proximity chat
oh they got they saw the Call of Duty
yeah your business and talk to them and
find out what's really going on you know
what that is that that's that engine
for fortnite and they're able to change
it on the go where it's like crazy like
because proximity chat was only really
popping on uh on Call of Duty for like
two weeks
the fact that that literally just came
out and they like okay this one's got
you okay
fired up they got you
and that's gonna cut down on a lot of
catfishing because dudes be out there
dancing like they girls
you be up on that and you're gonna hear
them say you hold on a second let me get
a pizza
oh God
you're crying oh man so that's good it's
still ready to go no no that that has
not been it oh
right here what's going on so um got the
midnight Suns I'm gonna give my
impression since we ain't talking about
that game oh here we go the attic went
in but let me hear it I'm gonna tell you
it's a mobile game that is wow yes man
360 games
I actually think that it looks like
Dragon H2 Graphics yes and I'm not
saying that's like the end-all be-all
king but it's like come on how you gonna
have a game looking like that like and
what's funny is even though I'm not a
huge fan of the the cards in the game
it's still fun gameplay but it's just
like that Graphics just hit man
60 frames per second the highest level
of of uh what is it Unreal Engine 4
Unreal Engine 3 Tech
um
super polished superpowers like when you
when you're able to run and run through
the forest you do it you feel like you
the flash everything is moving nothing's
breaking up in the world you're like oh
look at this the texture is not popping
it this is crazy yeah this is It's the
Most polished it's the most polished 360
level PS3 era Joy yeah yeah story
um I'm kind of feeling it I'm feeling it
like okay okay I wanted to talk to a
Marvel geek I'll be a comic geek because
I feel it
it's not it's just the felt die I feel
that the story is good
um I see as a comic book dude plenty of
times I have to dispel belief like I
feel what you're saying you know like uh
step away and accept what the artist is
painting what they're trying to do and
stop trying to interject my comic
knowledge oh that's not right you know
and I I know John Johnny Blaze
[Laughter]
but the story that they're crafting a
man a hunter out of time out of place
and I made my character I made me pretty
good yeah
yeah I was like yo this is dope I like
him I'm here and um
the leveling up system is cool
the card system I'm used to card systems
in games so
it's really the lucky to draw if you're
in a battle and you don't get the
missiles but you get a buff for this and
it's just about the strategy of it uh
sometimes you can get a crazy winning
hand and you can have a op blade or Op
ghost rider that's crazy whatever doing
something so
um or when you Captain Marvel and you
turn the Beanery y'all a body remote is
crazy she gets so op yeah
um
I thought it was well thought out I
thought it was very very it's the
highest polished 360 game PlayStation 3
game you're gonna get like don't look
with HDR we were crispy HDR yeah
beautiful eight yards pop it all over
the place HDR highlights the fact that
there's no um yes
everything is just super sharp yes uh
it's so I'm I'm happy for what they
produced I think this game was done long
time ago and they were just trying to
figure out certain things and they
probably implemented this card system in
very late after the fact it was gonna
probably be something else and they did
this but I don't know is it is it a
hundred dollar purchase no
um is it a Black Friday deal buy one get
one free deal yes if you want a good
story it's something to get into so I'm
not gonna tell you to turn uh completely
away where there's a lot of good games
out there yeah like God award you know
honest with you you know graphically
pushing these consoles nice this ain't
it though but it's a very good ROM man
no doubt is this game out on mobile
no I I'm really would not be surprised
in the next like two or three months it
comes out like a mobile version oh I see
you say like a down skin the super
dancer because it's just like I feel
like the reason it looks like this is
because they're making a mobile version
alongside it like they didn't want like
the two to be like drastically because
this is not ready they know there's
Legit Mobile games that look better than
this
it's just and I just I don't understand
how they thought these type of Graphics
would cut it in 2020. I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be real with you like
no doubt what's up man if I see you in
there boy and oh lucious Augustus I see
you what's up bro and of course we have
the gaming ninja himself the Shinobi
Lord Cognito spreading to the Roman IOP
not telling what you wanted but what you
need there shout out to my man Mr Maddie
plays to find and do it we made episode
100 very proud of the boy put his put
itself out there he's doing a lot right
now go check him out um obviously going
through some real life stuff and burnout
is real you know just to let y'all know
burnout is real even I'll be feeling it
so uh please check him out in his honest
video he's got out talking about it and
some things he's going to make some
adjustments we also did uh to find a new
Ultimate with whole law go check that
out breaking down the deal some more
updates on the situation and then uh
shout out to my brethren man shout out
to Barnes shot the tiger Travis grab my
man mactix on talking about the current
season talking about what's getting
ready for next season I don't know if
y'all want the rumors king or should I
leave that alone but somebody body
should be coming back for next season
prior to life fall so everybody's
talking about that no okay I'll keep it
AKA King they're going to the same
Planet they've all we've already been to
so
I'm gonna bring back Kate then I can't
come back we gotta get our money back
dude we're going back to the same Planet
they just got rid of uh so yeah well
allegedly so we've been doing that so
other than that I've been rocking
rocking vampire survivors I actually
threw it all okay see what they're like
let me see the
sophists all this game so I started on
eyes like I don't know
that's disgusting I know how you do it
yeah that I was like oh so then I get
the crystal all right so they'll pick a
faster dive pick this and then it's like
okay then you get this it's more faster
you get okay and then I got it then I
got the two Bibles I got the holy Bibles
running around I was like oh okay and
then I start getting more strong and I
was like ah did I pick I unlocked some
chick with a wand power that's the
strong one I was like okay I get it I
get it now and it is it's like kid was
saying it's like
yo you don't like anything but we got to
come back right now
more to that older gamer
how about your leg but anyway like like
I always said
um yeah I get it it's it's an addictive
loop it's a it's you know what it is
modern Robotron
but with Castlevania elements yep and
the fact that you always die at the end
but you you do this frenetic Pace kind
of stuff it's simple it's fun what is it
is it made by one guy is it maybe one
guy or no do we know honestly I don't
know okay but look it's addictive is it
like over I'm not gonna now I will go
with attic on this it's not oh my God
game of the year and I'm not there I'm
not like yo everybody better watch out
I'm not there but it is addictive
gameplay that is fun and I I do enjoy I
do enjoy I was I was pleasantly
surprised I was like wow this is really
fun knock on front I've been doing that
playing demio like crazy new um
adventure comes out next week and they
got the new character class for
barbarian started plague's tale started
plague's tail up that is a gorgeous game
that is a phenomenal gorgeous game I
love the stealth mechanics you know
learning about the macular what's going
on with Hugo I like the fact that it's
pure stealth and the vulnerability you
will get body if you get caught if
you're running out in these streets and
you making noise and you're doing things
you ain't supposed to do you are going
to get bodied so I like that joint um
what else I've been rocking and of
course but that sounds yeah so look
let's get right to it and this is where
attic I got to give him his he's
completely right
for axis
[Laughter]
I love you but we do got to talk about
this engine now you know what I'm saying
like like we do like bro like you guys
are the goats the let me get them they
balls they they are the goats of turn
base when it comes to turn base and then
not only in combat
strategy layer base layer no one does
that better they've done things on this
that are really fun the card system is
really fun you just gotta know how to
utilize it you got to know how to
utilize the redraw if they give you some
black cards you don't want you put the
Rejoice then you got to look at the
thing with the heroism meat on the side
so you can be stronger for powerful
moves in game
fine I'm cool right in game in in game
play Combat with the cards with the
thing and then they do a little cinnamon
Iron Man jump up Miss Marvel do binary
like it blade is crazy the bleed
mechanic that
is it's the problem is the 60 of the
game is outside of the combat which
reminds you to be in that church when
you in that church bro
it's like King said it's the most solid
PS3 360 error High it looked like an
Xbox come back with compatible game up
Reds like you don't say like it it's
just that foundational level like if you
use it Unreal Engine three yes that's
what it feels like when you finish I I
want to say one more thing yeah it is
just that's the and I'm like and that's
this is where attic is right as much as
he going first of all I love this game
this game is fire the gameplay they have
the basement cast I understand why they
went with the hunter a character that
you yourself am because then you could
tell them more story you can't be
Captain America in this you know what
I'm saying and then hiding behind you
can't do x-com with this you can't put
you know the Hulk behind cover and then
you'll say so I get it you know what I'm
saying and I get attic's point with he
would have preferred the x-com game I'm
just happy my dudes got the bag and
Marvel trust them with the license and
for the Geeks they are doing some real
deep
the side character dudes you know what
I'm saying the dudes that don't get the
light the midnight Suns the you know
what I'm saying the the almost like the
Marvel what is it the street level guys
but with a couple other dudes fire but
y'all got to step your engine up y'all
can't be into it y'all using the exit
I think it was deliberate I'm sorry like
they've had games look better than this
but I don't even think Chimera Squad but
they you sell shade it this is x-com two
water chosen yeah this is like bro like
you that that's my only issue because
it's like what's pissing me off the game
is so fire but yeah yo when he walk
around with the chair mail he looking
like Dragon Age
and let's keep it real king he had the
animation because you know you could
pick male or female he had the
animations that with the hips that look
like you could have anyway so do
whatever you know yeah yeah yeah
they die and what's sad about it is
you're gonna guys are gonna look at it
and say nah because of that I'm good
yeah you see what I'm saying
it's a shame because if they didn't
that's the same it ain't in Game Pass
but and the last thing I said is um the
reason why it's a shame because I'm
looking at gears tactics and addict we
know how gears tactics engine out of
Base in Base Cinema that's why I gotta
say attic is on to something yeah they
did it on purpose yeah well maybe he's
right and maybe he's on to something
with the maybe it's a mobile crossover
maybe they're going all out with this
bag but that's my only disappointment
because I know people say is there
microtransactions in the game
um they're suits that's Cosmetics
Cosmetics it's definitely gonna be on
mobile yeah so that that's what I was
gonna say but I absolutely love it I'm
at the park right now where stuff is
going I like they got a friend they got
they got Lego friends so they got like a
Tinder in game you can sit there so so
yeah so this this funny this is the
thing that that so what is the the whole
sort of social
because since we was talking about 360
games yes yes
um gun grave Gore okay okay let's go all
right so I I love the original gun grave
and he runs around and he feels as heavy
and cumbersome as he does and clunky as
he does because he's running around with
a casket on his back
he swings said casket to knock his
enemies
he uses the chains and stuff off of the
the casket off his back to bring the
enemies close it is the most mindless
fun
douchey game from the 360 era and I love
it I love I remember when games like
this was like 50 cents to the blood in
the sand and all this other stuff those
games was coming out and it was like
they were all following this game
Corridor shoot it up bang it up see how
much Gore that they could put on the
screen how much you can wow a person and
have a crazy kill count and that's all
it is about smacking bullets back at
people it's it's it's clunky it's it's
it's cumbersome the control's gonna get
in the way the graphics ain't all the
way polished but this is PlayStation 3
360 era fun and it's polished so we're
getting all these old games
and they like you know clean them up
ship them out and it's 60 frames let's
go yes I think that's exactly what's
going on I think that seems to be the
theme
so the Polish was there because remember
what we heard I was like oh damn it's
broken it's
he's not right I mean not wrong in what
he said he's absolutely right but
because he's he's judging it by today's
standards right I'm judging it by
exactly where they put it they put it
back there in the PlayStation that were
in the 360 era and that's when gun grave
came out right so gun grave Gore took so
long to come out it still has the whole
essence of gun grade it's still the same
game with the upgrades I got you yeah I
just wondering if it's overall a
generational thing the fact that yeah we
haven't seen I'm just talking about in
general with gaming like we haven't seen
that jump yet nope for most of most of
it most of the channels so far so
hopefully we'll see it but that's been
pretty much it so if you want to get to
uh the business and sure let me get
these super chats first and then we'll
get to the business no doubt hold on one
second let me see if there's anything
else popped in I got everything else
though let me see
okay I will go so
first up we got Bounty happen for one
year 16 months actually wag one IRP
enough respect called the while Adam
King
let's go crazy how you were saying yeah
he just flipped that like I was like yo
who's talking right now
you know Hey listen uh you know anybody
looking for voice actors like yo bro
listen shout out to Farms you know what
I'm saying because I was doing his thing
I'm proud of you far as game talk live I
see you but I told you that one of the
best radio voices games
but my man is dead nice too let's do it
talk to me
new Kratos yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you sir appreciate that absolutely
then we got Forza Legend five dollar
Super Chat I love Forza but I will say
Need for Speed Unbound has the best
street feel racing game and plus
customization is definitely one of the
best in the races that's the Need for
Speed coming out of nowhere everybody
thought they're done for it and all of a
sudden it's like I'm gonna have to check
this out at some points
yeah
accesses should be there you know but if
it's selling maybe it'll get there
slower
we'll see you in a year because that's
what that's coming a lot of stuff I got
a lot of stuff
morning Lords after seeing those AI
pictures I think y'all are gonna have to
add philosopher to addicts interests
your philosopher
you're a philosopher yes
yes I am yes
Hector the Macho Man 10 super chat oh
hell the Lord so many fans were claiming
Callisto before the meta score now
they're treating it like a Snapchat
it played better over here but it stinks
yeah but but you know that's about it
that's where the conversation is
but they do get their parent style from
Kratos wipe your feet off before you
come in
lessons absolute then we got RMB AKA The
Underground game what ten dollars to
protect hope we don't have to wait two
plus years after release to hear God of
War Ragnarok finally reached 10 million
sails like the last of us two wbg
podcasts and disregard no doubt thank
you [ __ ]
we're gonna wait to hear that they ain't
gonna let those numbers out the door
it's like Black Adam oh man
they make the numbers
yeah oh no yeah it didn't even cover the
spread oh do they say oh I'm pulling for
that David Yuri on let me know what's
going on
digital sales
are you saying they should have used
that as the tax right office
dope I saw it twice oh man man God bless
you in the world I love what he tried to
do I love what he tried I didn't care
about what he wanted
if the world didn't come out for the
rock that's crazy
yeah what oh man
double plastic
don't do the rock like this he waited 15
15 years to catch the l oh man they'll
do it don't do it his way below I'm
enjoyed that crazy yeah
I loved it the world didn't
but that's that's kind of crazy that
that didn't move units like that but
like all this stuff bro yeah like what
was the what was the the boat one that
he did the the Disney one whatever it
was I know the one where he was lost in
he was a vote Captain yeah lion dude
yeah I give like a thousand years that
killed dude like that yeah I don't know
you know how to push Disney stuff this
is
we still talking about Black Adam
is done with Black Adam moving on yeah
well no and I I liked it but it's like
at the end of the day I I think that
Disney or not Disney uh DC's lost a lot
of like Faith like the fans have lost a
lot of faith in them so it's just like a
lot of people aren't willing to take
gambles on DC movies anymore so it's
crazy because he fought so hard to to
get you know people in there that
haven't seen it you know whatever and
make specific changes and I guess yeah
it didn't land only tickets he sold was
the free ones hello I mean it's just one
of those things where it's like if they
if they stand behind him and let him
spend more money to try to build that
Universe they could have something but
it's just like you gotta prove to people
okay we're doing comic books differently
now we're doing our movies differently
now I was able to strong arm in the
building that's what made this so
surprising to me that I thought because
remember the fan score was so hot we'll
see at this point people show up for
these movies for a universe
and he's going to be controlling the Arc
of it that's the director of Guardians
of the Galaxy all three movies so if you
like that style you like that stuff uh
that's gonna be all over there the
universe is officially yeah if they
start doing good story building and
stuff like that I feel like you'll start
to see you know people actually having
interest in that franchise but until
they show that I just don't see you
having a lot of people that's gonna mess
with it right now like you gotta show
like look this isn't just because let's
be real here everyone here has seen a DC
movie thought it was good and they did
nothing with it later on yeah they're
good they're good and like they're good
in silos yeah as a cohesive thing like
yeah good point and until they prove to
people that look where where this the
Long Haul I just don't see a lot of
people having faith in watching a movie
like they're looking at that like oh
that that that's an HBO Max when it pops
over there like you know that people
don't do that with Disney because
there's an actual Universe building on
Disney and until they prove they're
building a Universe on DC people are not
going to trust them entirely yeah we
gotta see anyway but we got so we chat
then we got Forza Legend again two
dollars to pretend Need for Speed
Unbound meant to say that but
autocorrect shaking my head no need to
protect that I knew what you meant back
you good bro
then we got
um himanshu yadav
40 rupee Super Chat I just noticed man
king looks like a dead like Derek
chisora yo
you're gonna stop being disrespected all
right so you sat there and watched that
fight that I did not call yesterday
because he a
bums
talk about that second Mario movie
trailer you couch why y'all talking
about Mario it was the illest it was the
illest
a compilation of Mario it did Mario
Stars Mario Galaxy uh Mario Kart they
did uh Mansion all types of stuff
that's what all I need to do is added
gonna go see Mario is he in yeah
that's a premiere date I actually I I
messed with it I I like what I see like
with the graphics to your liking it's
great yeah I mean put it that's not even
the same thing look at you yeah that's
right I'll be Embassy with you was it up
to stuff
so I don't I don't like I don't like
Marvel midnight Sons
play 30 to 10 15 per second Pokemon
games and Nintendo's all good but here
come by game we get the 10th degree yeah
I Gotta See actual gameplay that's right
I've just seen trailers I'm trying to
see you gotta be in my feelings this
morning
anyway moving up move it up all right
there we got THX 1138 two dollar Super
Chat the world to Black Adam nope
yo don't do that The Rock was trying
though it's feeling you
I like I don't even think people people
don't have faith in the Rock I think
people have faith in DC nah I think it's
him oh damn wow
that he didn't have Black Adam ears oh
the thing is yes yeah yeah is they kind
of eliminated that I was like I went
back and I watched the film hey yo
moving on let me see what uh some
receipts
nope we're good we're caught up all
right okay on to the rest of business is
that time of the month to say thank you
to our patreon subscribers thank you so
much give back a little bit and that the
holiday season so we're gonna start off
uh with uh an extra giveaway because
shout out shout out to Lord flame Lord
flame wanted to pay forward his uh
probably tribe of the month win yeah
yeah exactly so he wanted to pay forward
his uh scribe of the month win so he
just said you know just feed it out
there to the community
yeah we put words in his mouth
your whole intro now I will freestyle
your whole Jake the price can go to the
next guy yes yes all right so the winner
of uh Lord frame this flank frames
Flames uh subscriber of the month award
yes
Craig Cahill
that's crazy that's that's Ireland in
the building that's the homies oh man
I'm out with the ham shipping's going on
here
we gotta make that right continue we
gotta make it right we gotta make it
right no no that's crazy then we have
okay let's go bike back down to our ten
dollar gift card giveaway
and that goes to
[Music]
Philip corpening shout out to Phillip
carpening yeah sir there's some new
names
all right we're not rigging the
situation no more no bags being dropped
off
you know don't stop the count and all
that exactly game game awards take
notice
you know people switch sides and change
their names you know we don't know free
R Kelly anymore he didn't change that
he's a changed man I know the ultimate
Xbox game
whatever
so what I was doing the raid uh not the
right I was playing Crystal product
and I get to this part
and there's a bunch of cells everywhere
people are dead in the South blood
everywhere and someone said yo that's
that's R Kelly so you just passed back
like this damn not good not good not
good savagery continue let me see hold
on a second so we did that so we're
going to our 20 gift card giveaway right
I'm not bugging here
um 20 gift card giveaway and that goes
to
[Music]
cybernox shout out to cybernet I know
that name slow salute so I've been
knocking about you sir cybernucks take
that bread right now and run over to the
deals with um the I forgot what games
are the the Assassin Creed dudes those
dudes over there right those games is
buy one get the next dude free all right
one in the cart right now the next dude
that you throw in that cart is free take
that 20 and get it up go do it salute
this is where on the where is this
um
I have all that stuff yeah I know it
sucks would it be a good deal but you
got I don't have Valhalla so
um
all right oh right yeah you get that
um you'll be there for two years
all right and our Teespring giveaway for
the month of December goes to Bros
say that's the homie that's my own oh
salute thank you
thank you to all of you for all the help
and support you give us throughout the
year we could not do it without you
again this is a lot of the stuff that's
happening patreon yeah uh um what you
may call it YouTube subscriptions
everything that you see that the mics
that we got cameras that's all because
of this so thank you so we appreciate
you guys much love to community shout
out to the merch store see somebody cop
the unisex zip hoodie with the IOP Crest
on it salute to y'all and then somebody
got the stainless steel tumbler 20 ounce
ILP Unity Edition with all the colors on
across the wolf I'm seeing you and then
somebody got Yo somebody picked up throw
them in the bushes
throwback somebody threw them in the
bushes yeah man you got to go get Buck
man go Get Buck baby yeah you got to get
it yeah you gotta buck up though that
book is that book is crazy wow yeah
yeah graphic artist is just a beast look
at this go get this try the graphic
guard you know you know damn well shout
out to the OG the bushes
I gotta talk to Suave
conversations you gotta make sure that
joint is awful through the pool actually
a couple of um things are solved oh yeah
the number one was really important yeah
yeah it says Lord I saw this on on
Twitter yesterday
um it says Lord remember for four months
my hospital visits went well Thursday
now one now wanting for the next phase
towards my kidney transplant TV guys for
thank you guys not TV thank you guys for
keeping my spirits up each week thank
you brother man wish you all the best
yes obviously
and then we have said Lord again five
dollar Super Chat also my older sister
celebrated her one year anniversary for
her transplant yesterday fantastic
blessings I would love to see you on
demand and we can provide any comfort
any laughs any jokes exactly we we
really appreciate it so salute the
absolutely that means a lot
and we are caught up yeah right last
week's polls in and the people spoken to
the question if the potential Microsoft
acquisition of Activision Blizzard King
is blocked by Regulators which
concession do you think Xbox should make
in hopes of getting the deal approved
the winner of our four-way ILP poll with
65 percent of the vote was Call of Duty
should remain on Playstation like
Minecraft was group coming in at second
with 15 of the vote was the messy Lords
I don't care I'm blocking everything to
protect my PlayStation in the third
place at a close ten percent of the vote
was Call of Duty parody on PlayStation
Plus like Game Pass and in La I can't
kick it out at the last place eight
percent of the vote was Call of Duty
must be removed from Game Pass group
shout out to all those who love voters
definitely gonna fall into that
King yeah your thoughts they want it
like a Minecraft situation I mean that's
the biggest the smartest thing to do and
and the Microsoft wanted that way too
let them pay we why not milk them dry
man you know just to take everything for
take them for what they got they want it
right hey you want it we got it over
here you can go get it in Game Pass but
you won't pay so you won't pay let's
let's get it while they won't pay man
and the funny one the funny one is the
one about PS plus parody because if that
if that comes up like if if Jim has the
audacity to ask for that right but like
now I'm not budging until you give me
this
I I can see him being
so outlandish like listen
this ain't happening unless you get it
exactly I can see it I can talk when you
want it all at all costs it all turns
around and be like cool that's gonna be
a smooth 500 mil up front
nah I only want 500 mil up front I want
the exact number of what they did last
year I want the exact number so if they
did you know all 800 million on your
console we want exactly the figure that
they did up front up front then you can
have it yeah
I've done anyway so that's that the new
poll will be up go check that out this
is my topic I set it off God Howard
outside huge interview recently I've got
the gentlemania my name is Lex Friedman
Friedman always bear Friedman yeah
tremendous interviews I checked out his
channel this dude I don't know how the
hell he get his interviews yo I don't
know who he's connected to I don't know
what he's doing I don't know what's up
what cult he's with
at all because if you look at how
diverse and how
um Elon Musk this dude don't play he's
up there with Joe Rogan yeah bro he had
the Rizza on one I was like I was like
yo it's just such a they were talking
about nod I'm like what is going on who
is your agent yeah he's doing it really
big and it's it's cool to see when I was
actually checking out the channel which
I found him for the first time because
of the times
there's a ton of stuff I'm gonna try to
paraphrase quickly as much stuff talked
about Starfield let's get into Starfield
talk um solar systems and identify by
levels so pretty much kind of like
there's gonna be zones in the solar
system where like yo like you don't want
to be in there until you like level 25
or you would get by like it's not gonna
be marked on the map from my
understanding but there's going to be
zones in the game as far as the solar
system so that was there 1 000 plus
planets
um was generated using procedural
technology where they generate our
landscape they hand craft some things
and then a tool sack some engine kind of
wraps around the planet Blends them
together and he said they built through
their experience of Daggerfall the
Skyrim Daggerfall DC as a touch point
for some of the planet stuff
um spacesuits have different Buffs to
fight off gases and toxicity so certain
planets certain areas you're going to be
in like if you've got certain suits are
going to be a big part of the game all
right talked about Elder Scrolls 6 uh
release date has a vague idea Todd has a
vague idea what it is he said he
indicates not soon but they want to make
um Elder Scrolls 6 last for decades kind
of the same way uh Skyrim is not been
loaned he said he's known for a while
where the actual location of Elder
Scrolls 6 is going to be in Tamriel you
know I'm saying so we'll be set or as
far as Xbox he says a culture that
players see is the same on the inside
like it's the real deal Holyfield he's
all the way live with it he said he
really likes working with the Xbox
Hardware team he said I'm really a holy
family
I'm laughing at he he that he gotta say
man you know she she like how she say
she is man like you know she real down
the Earth too man she's really into
astrology yeah yeah he said he really
loves working with the hardware team and
he said anything he's at the series X
consoles he's very impressed and now
being able to just focus down on one
console as well as obviously the PC
um we talked about Fallout show he said
he said he confirmed that they're going
to retell they're not going to retell a
Fallout story in this team so basically
what he said is they gonna pick a
section of the map they're going to
decide where it's going to be they're
going to have references there may be
some references to the games but it's
gonna be original so if they want to do
Fallout you know same friend I think
yeah yeah the cool thing is like with
Fallout you could for every season if it
goes past one season right you could
pick a different Vault every season and
do something crazy like that that's the
potential like to see as soon as you go
anywhere so he said he was out they're
excited about that talked about the
Indiana Jones game he said he reiterated
that machine games was a perfect fit
unlike his original team because they
had the deal earlier and Todd was going
to do it with his team
and now he says um machine games is the
perfect fit he said calls it a mashup
Indian the new Indiana Jones game a
mashup and he's not intentionally not
only one thing there's way more bars
there's way more information try to get
as much of the stuff that people were
asking about so yeah again I don't know
if anybody saw it or just any of these
statements that I'm reading interest you
let's start with Lord addict are you
feeling about any of the stuff that God
Howard he don't come outside often
yeah I think um you know it's the only
thing I'm a little skeptical with is
you know when they try to
make a game bigger than it actually is
I'm concerned with a little bit of fluff
on Starfield uh especially the same
terms like a thousand plans to think for
the most part those thousand planets
they don't ever intend on you going to
those planets it's just something like
kind of an adventure thing so I think
that's mainly what it is uh when they
say they've they've you know they've
crafted some of the planets I think
right there you're looking at okay here
we have all these Brazilian generated
stuff that you can get materials from
you could kill people you can get uh
equipment from but these planets is
where the actual stories and the
missions are that's what I told batty I
think the same thing yeah because
remember like even Mass Effect one
solved yeah remember they were certain
lies that you and then you unlock a
mission and the cool thing I want to add
I'll give it back to you Adam is he said
I forgot to mention they had a part
where they was putting in you could run
out of fuel and and then they were like
yeah but then it became not fun when you
got stuck because they like you ran out
of food and you had to throw up with the
stress signal you got to see who get you
who picked you up or whatever he's like
here you know how he feel about that but
I just want to add that what other
comments uh you want to talk about with
Todd and I mean when it comes to
exactly how everything ran like I'm just
kind of curious like did people really
not think Bethesda wasn't close with
Microsoft before this purchase oh we
doing it like it's crazy because I you
know
in a way you could say
that they have nurtured Bethesda from
the ground up and a lot of their console
influences are you implying that this
relationship they didn't just go swoop
up an evil this isn't an organic
relationship
the funny thing is it's like this is
like one of those things where you look
at it
um I feel like
organically
it's taken out of context sometimes like
if you just funnel money into a company
because you're working uh exclusive
deals with them I don't feel like you're
organically building that company up
because all you're doing is giving them
money you're not helping them find
Talent you're not helping them with
anything on the technical issues you're
just buying timed exclusive that's the
life
but but
I'm talking I gotta watch you do this
hey man we're a team now oh my God
no way man I gave you some cash man
together
as far as Elder Scrolls six uh don't
expect this game anytime soon but the
the funny thing is like he's like we've
we've known for a while where this in
this this place is gonna be and I'm like
like
uh I'm like tall you showed us a trailer
and you didn't think that the community
doesn't know where this game's gonna be
like it's like you showed us clear like
clear Landscaping of the area in in
Elder Scroll sticks in that trailer and
you didn't think that these tryhard
Elder Scroll fans and and you know RPG
fans in general weren't going to be able
to find out where in tamboro this this
location is like I think that they said
it's uh there's two places it could be
it's like hammerfell or I can't remember
the second place like when I spoke to
Maddie he said
um the place where the red guards is at
with that because you know the regards
is the more people so I like I have a
rake on it every every Skyrim yeah yes
it's a little bit of Red Gods is that
let's go okay
I hope just for the sake it just to piss
everybody off with all the predictions
he's gonna be over here with the lizard
people no it's gonna be with the records
it just means a whole new Island that he
just made up no what's funny is like I
saw someone and I'm not I'm not gonna
say any names but I saw someone on
another podcast like a a bigger podcast
say that oh well you know what I'm just
playing I'm glad to think the Elder
Scrolls games I'm just glad that they're
they're not connected and I'm like are
you are you an idiot like
Elder Scrolls is in one timeline off of
a continent like it just it kills me
that you got people that cap for Brands
they know nothing about the bowl slave
red guards immune disease you play
Skyrim my ability I know you play that
red card that's why I'll be picking them
bro
touch my soul cause I said dude that
play that game he plays that game salute
continue song it's just funny because
in in Skyrim if you read a lot of the
books that come you come across they'll
literally tell you on what happened in
Oblivion like it's just people really
think that Elder Scrolls is like
one-offs like kind of like you know
Fallout is kind of connected too but
it's not as connected as the uh the uh
the Elder Scrolls games it's just like
crazy man and you know what's funny King
people people sit here talking all this
stuff about Starfield
oh what's this gonna do what's that I'm
gonna tell you right now oh what you're
seeing with Starfield is going to be a
fraction of the salt you're gonna see
when Elder Scrolls sixes announced as an
Xbox
PC exclusive speaking of which he
already went straight for it yeah you
know how it is he said on camera this is
an exclusive to Xbox you know how it is
people are going to hold off all you
know they'll change their mind during
development yeah until that comes out
and it says only on Xbox and PC you know
they're gonna hold that hope I want the
I want to see the hoping their eyes die
oh that's what I want to see
snitch again
they hope Jim finds a way
they still have people yeah you saw
people asking
um Todd Howard is Starfield and
exclusive in the games damn you're out
at this point right so it's just like
you know these people are gonna they're
gonna live off whatever they can for
this Elder Scrolls game it's funny it is
it's just like look like you can say
what you want they dropped the ball for
Fallout 76. and they did you know one of
the studios did it wasn't the key studio
that makes all the games but they did
still drop the ball and they deserve
that smoke yes but no one can't deny I I
would I I don't know I have to look do a
little research but I'm curious
if there's another Studio that has more
Game of the Year wins then that's a good
point and I'm glad you said that because
look I get skepticism on Starfield from
a new IP standpoint I get that but I'm
with you that the reason why I get a
little upset is like we're not gonna act
like they did not make like three to
four games of the generations prior to
that you know what I'm saying so it's
just like that we just not gonna act
like the Fallout series you know that
didn't do anything prior to that we're
not going to act like Skyrim was
literally arguably one of the greatest
games ever made We're Not Gonna Act Like
Oblivion was not one of the groups 360.
Fallout 3 yeah
Morrowind again as an OG Xbox game get
to it Morrowind when it came I think
what was the term you used before Xbox
gamer you use the term specifically oh
gee right so OG meaning like Original
Gangster that he was there from the
beginning from the beginning
I just gotta get this all so we're going
to say that this company that only
developed on PC prior right and had
talked to Xbox since its Inception right
and made a console game for the first
time right and it was exclusive to the
OG Xbox right then Oblivion came out was
exclusive to the 360. we're going to say
the day we did it for the beginning and
that relationship was it was not organic
okay okay I just want to make sure that
we we cleared that this was a you know
each other
listen it's just again it to me it's not
even about going there it's to me it's
just like we have to we we can't pick
and choose right just because you know
which game doesn't count if it's
successful on a platform we can't so
that that's all I'm trying to say we
have to be very cognizant because if we
do that then you know what else we could
do if we're gonna play that game we can
say well Final Fantasy isn't yours
because that was Nintendo's from the big
you see what I'm saying and we get into
this semester and it's not even
PlayStations in general another whole
game the whole company so at the end of
the day right as long as it comes out on
the platform and it's successful that
you help it get across the finish line
or you help it even become creative
that's part of organic growth period
like that that that's just what it is we
can't take credit and meddles away I'm
sorry I just had to get that off
yeah it's no longer a solo project we
are organically learned so I just got to
be careful with all this semantics and
it doesn't count and all this stuff
they wanted built from inside the house
with the brand on the face first the
majority of stuff is not even built like
that yeah but I mean
even even even the stuff that evolved
into you know they so the thing about it
is like when you buy something early on
just because it happened 20 years ago
and and these companies evolved into
something else under that again it's
still you purchased it at a certain
point you purchased it for a reason
right whatever that IP was that was big
at the time or whatever you purchased it
for that initially and then you evolve
into something else right and that's
great that's organic growth but but
again
the same arguments that are being made
at the Inception of this relationship
happen at the Inception of every
relationship that's the same thing
happened 20 years ago same thing
Insomniac same thing a lot of these a
lot of these Studios yeah it's just it's
just again you're seeing the fruits of
it now correct but if you go back to the
beginning of it this you know they it
was it was a girl exactly
she just dated you for a second you was
a phase [ __ ]
I am saying that
it's like I said there's a lot of people
upset over Starfield but
when Elder Scrolls 6 starts dropping
info and we start seeing gameplay and we
start seeing trailers for the story yeah
I don't think people
realize the salt that's gonna happen
like because right now I think it's so
far out that people aren't really
registering but when you start seeing
this game it's like I said
Bethesda You could argue that Bethesda
is what's wrong looking for they are
what you looking for like the god like
one of the OG Godfathers of the
developing Studios like and it's like I
said you can argue that they have the
most games of the years that's ever any
Studio's ever done the only people I
could see that they could give them a
room for their money is Rockstar because
of the GTA franchise and the Red Dead
franchise like you took it you look at
it Oblivion Morrowind Skyrim Fallout 3.
like these most of these games were game
of the year every
Outlets made these games games of the
year actually there's people that
consider
Skyrim one of the greatest games ever
made if not the greatest game you gotta
get back to their winning ways I had to
have one day listen they slept on the
banana field with somebody I mean that
wasn't them really right
organically speaking
oh that's what we do it today okay
so why I was laughing because all I
heard in my head was when Skyrim came
out you know if you think you
when it comes to that I I think that
Todd Howard just said it he's like look
you know we had help back then and
nothing's changed Microsoft's still
helping us develop these games I mean no
one should have looked past when Todd
Howard came on stage and said when
Fallout 76 went down as one of the worst
games and worst performing games ever
made the first person I called a
suspense yeah that's a problem
you don't even really got to go past
that that's literally all you got to
look at you know like that's a good
point you know first person he should
call his lawyer
yeah they was coming if you didn't hear
how the conversation went
yeah I was I was trying to do something
a little organically you know are you
saying are you saying to feel so blood
in the snow
when times are hard
hey baby what's up keep in mind
it could easily
oh maybe the the Elder Scrolls you know
days are over but it's just like until
we see that next installment you can't
say that I don't like so almost every
time the studio and you know what's
gonna really you know what's gonna
really sting a lot of people is
Starfield Comes Out Swinging yeah
if Starfield Comes Out Swinging it's
gonna be one of those situations like
I got it oh God but oh God like because
now they're gonna have to look at this
standpoint that's like
we messed up so In fairness I gotta play
Devil's Advocate you know I got to keep
it fair for the other side but In
fairness he did say this is the most
pressure he's felt in a long time and
it's the fact that let's be real they've
had that Cadence of Elder Scrolls game
so these are things that they used to
right so Starfield is a whole different
beast and that's why when to hear him
say yo you know kind of feeling it and
now the delay and all that stuff makes
sense because it's like yo we cannot and
he even said it like this is gonna be
looked at his Xbox's first you know what
I mean like from us and we set in the
wave right so it is a lot of pressure on
them to deliver I got some more
questions I want to ask but I'll let you
I just want to get he did mention that
bar on that but I'll let you finish and
then we move on that's pretty much all
man it's like you know I understand
people are skeptical and they should be
skeptical you know I don't personally
blame them like I'm not gonna hit them
too hard for 76 because I I do
understand that that was a different
Studio but regardless if it was a
different Studio when you wear the
Bethesda software name even if you're a
different part a different studio with
that name you're still gonna get hit
it's just like
it's just like Halo 343 regardless if
that's Halo and three four three we're
still gonna blame Microsoft just simply
because they did that that's how it go
that's how I go no doubt Lord Sovereign
God how it outside lots of talk you can
take it from anything what things
interested you I mean I mean going back
to all those topics like we
know how I feel about Starfield
Starfield is to me the only thing that
worries me about that and I don't know
that I'm worried about it it's just
about I'm worried about the reaction
people
that people will have to just another if
if it is just another Skyrim Oblivion
slash Fallout type game in space right
and it and it doesn't sort of expand on
on the things that you know very
honestly they created right they created
this type of RPG so that's my worry you
know for me I I don't really subscribe
to the idea of like just more is better
bigger you know a bigger world you know
a thousand planets that worries me more
than anything I like okay I like density
like to me if you would have said hey
man the game the game world is smaller
but you can go into every building or
something like that or every planet
every planet right or every planet is
created is that you know you don't you
don't have this procedurally generated
stuff that would be more exciting to me
I'm gonna play it I'm gonna play it I
know it's gonna be amazing it's just
when I look at next gen and what I want
from Next Gen I want that as opposed to
just bigger or more and and it feels
like that's what Todd likes like I'm
gonna impress you with the scale of this
thing and you know and again like his
size
[Laughter]
you don't you know what he trying to
impress you with the size
I said skills
but I think I think my my My worry is
about um Elder Scrolls six are the same
right the Elder Scrolls
yeah Skyrim is like such a special game
man like even to this day somebody
grabbed played Skyrim for the first time
like what the hell is this I've never
had this much choice this is insane to
this day this game is 11 12 years old at
this point so
there's a lot of pressure with Elder
Scrolls and there's a lot of pressure
with Starfield because it's a new thing
but Elder Scrolls has to hit of course
and I'm gonna be honest I I wonder if
Phil was being honest when he says at
the round table right after after they
join forces when he says it's gonna be a
game by game base I want to know so you
think the door's still open for
PlayStation on this I just don't know
how they personally Skyrim is is their
biggest property ever bigger than four
Skyrim is transcendent
yeah so it's just one of those things
that you know things change and we'll
see because numbers a lot of times
we have to always remember that behind
the scenes numbers dictate a lot and
just never know
um if by that time Game Pass numbers are
insane and maybe they've been able to
get you know Xbox you know game pass on
other platforms maybe if streaming is is
in a lot better place and then you know
a lot of other countries are using that
as more and I won't say primary but but
a more useful way to engage with Game
Pass right thing I could see them like
man you know what is no need to put any
place else is the situation still fluid
based on how the progression of game
packs numbers and things progress yeah
absolutely I mean this business is
business and again I it's just one of
those things like when Phil came out and
be like yeah it's a game by game basis I
know we've all sort of kind of settled
into the idea that it's going to be
these new these new IP that are
definitely going to be you know brand
new into into Game Pass and they're not
going anyplace else but you just just
never know like they never really fully
they never truly Define what Legacy
meant okay and and you always leave the
door and Phyllis said it himself he's
like you know you always you can't be
too definitive with what you say until
you're absolutely sure what you're going
to do so okay that that's interesting to
me but but with the game itself yeah I
just want them to really take a look at
what's going on around them other games
I don't want to have the same thing that
happened with Fallout 4 where it came
out and it was great it was more Fallout
but other games that kind of eating this
luncheon in a lot of different ways
right The Witcher had come out and it's
like oh man like the wit The Witcher
could be this what happened with Fallout
so there was some disappointment there
was still a great game I enjoyed it but
I don't want that you know head down
kind of in a in a dungeon somewhere and
not paying attention to what's happening
around you so you can be ready to come
out and wow because to me first time you
see Fallout 3 first time you're gonna
see Oblivion like this is running on
360. what the hell like it so I just
feel like past Skyrim we haven't had
that feeling from them like wow this is
the next step this is so something and
to me they they've always been that when
you Morrowind Oblivion uh Skyrim Fallout
3 those games come on people like what
the hell this is the next step they'll
sell right there is a hell of a run
that's why they should have blocked that
deal that was it yeah yeah
so I hope I'm wrong about uh Starfield
in that regard
um and then the stuff with Indiana Jones
yeah what's interesting to me is like
it's going to be an amalgamation of a
whole bunch of different genres right
yeah mashup so I mean I still I still
don't think that means it's going to be
a first person game at heart and it's
gonna have certain elements I think it's
going to be a third person action game
because it's indie
you know you have the movie coming out I
think next year whatever I don't know
how far along they are in development
but it feels like that's the third
person if there was ever a chance to
give you that hashtag plus one with a
known character and a known entity there
you have it make it a third person game
maybe you have first person puzzle
solving elements that make it more sort
of you know Uncharted when you solve
puzzles and stuff it's all third person
or whatever it's not super in-depth
maybe you can make it more in depth if
you make it first person same thing with
like a driving sequence or something
like that maybe they jump back and forth
in that way I still think the primary
way you're gonna play that game is third
person My Hope right
um and they're very I mean again seeing
games when it comes to action and like
moving from scene to scene bombastic
sort of but when you think about the
basic stuff that happened in Wolfenstein
the New Order
um and then you go into uh the old blood
and then you go into New Colossus
shout out to clutch man he got the
premiere on natty T he had to buy
another dryer burnt my first one have a
great show oh he got the Oh Daddy don't
put them in the dryer bro
yeah
and then yeah cold water and then you
hang it up don't buck up on me with that
dude
have all the kids where don't buck up on
me down there you know getting these
toys
and then last I mean the the we talked
about the SL Xbox that was that was a
fit if there's ever been a fit that's a
fit and you know just everything kind of
they were at a point where they had
taken some chances where you know with
things like uh the Dishonored series
which I love all that stuff it just
wasn't you know obviously the Fallout 7
76 SNAP food it they just weren't
hitting the way they needed them to hit
so they were in a position where it was
it made a whole lot of sense to to
partner with somebody and hey you know
Phil was there you know the bag was
there right there conveniently right
there so exactly
just in case I believe I believe the
word is
serendipitous
I think more great things a lot of great
things are gonna come out of this
partnership so that's that I think the
the coolest thing was one of the last
things he said about like when they
asked him he asked some general
questions about like the meaning of life
yeah he was getting deep with it and he
said something to the effect of like uh
I he like a quote from like Confucius or
something where he was like you know
everybody everybody has two lives right
and he said like the second life begins
when you realize you only have one life
right so it's like whatever rut you've
been in whatever routine you've had to
that point when you realize hey
my time here is limited how do I press
the reset button a little bit and enjoy
things more and do different things and
kind of have that have that like second
coming of of an individual and be like
okay this is life part two right that
you know we got to remember man like he
may not look it but you know Todd Howard
is he's up there in age at some point
he's going to want to retire actually
um so you know beyond Elder Scrolls six
who knows how much of a real sort of
Hands-On approach he's gonna have with
the rest of those games
um so you know and enjoy Todd Howard
still being in the mix while we still
have him because I think to be honest
with you I'd be surprised if he makes it
to uh to that before retiring I think he
he might retire mid-development of Elder
Scrolls 6 or if he doesn't do that he'll
retire like right after Elder Scrolls
six yeah no doubt Lord King God Howard
outside rare appearance anything stick
out to you sir yeah that just let me
know that um starfield's coming a whole
lot faster than y'all think of course
are you since New York have you calmed
myself um
you ain't getting off the hook for that
you said what you said you promised what
you promised you gonna get what you
gonna get we gonna get what we want okay
if it ain't ready see you in November
that you can go away with that but um
one of one one of the shippables yes yes
yes uh it's about to go because your man
you know Todd I would have sitting there
he was he was looking ready man he was
letting all the tea out he said you know
you know for a long time you know
Microsoft was a sneaky link you know um
we would slide off and we would meet him
and slide off when we was in this side
you know we thought about what console
we can
we had such a good building relationship
you know we was always BFFs you know
Microsoft never judged me for the things
so Fallout 76 went low
you know Phil was like hey man what's up
yeah man I tried it
it didn't go right well you know how
about if I throw it inside Game Pass we
can get a couple of hours it didn't
happen I could push you I could Market
you you know the world could see what
you got cause you got a lot to offer boo
it's like oh you do that for me
slit it inside Game Pass number started
looking good see you was right the whole
time I know I got your back man I got
your back it's thick and thin man we're
gonna be in this yeah organically
organic um
so then it was like yo
um the mortgage a little backed up um
you know we got a couple of things that
we got to do to the house and I didn't
know how to ask the ball the money
borrow the money you've been doing this
organically
let me put a ring on and let the world
know me and me you was together it's way
back from okay from the beginning so
what well what about the games that I
got in development you know I'll let you
decide
you got Choice boo boo say
it's all yours Daddy you know you know
you know what we see he was saying well
what about also I'll let you decide and
then he's like low-key on the side
that's like but you know I I am I'm
getting you out of bad situation yeah
you remember that so this so there's the
thing though so that until you think
that the little concession you know you
can keep Elder Scrolls Online over there
yeah she said but you know um those
those other people I don't want to call
us waves wave daddy so what what should
I do
[Applause]
all those games that it was over there
uh they could they could rock with those
you know we put them in the service
that's that's a great idea so what about
the new stuff new stuff all yours there
it is there it is so so uh Starfield the
new baby the one we've been working on
how we gonna work that oh that's all us
okay
Scrolls you know you're a little younger
number six he coming through us oh
that's all us Daddy
[ __ ] someone said you should call him
dummy
tell these dudes right now they feeling
the heat because they know this is just
a seven billion dollar acquisition
and they tell you they gave you the peek
under the hood you know Microsoft is
what they said they are they don't
bother us we make our games they give us
time you know and I messed it up that
was my bad so I'm gonna sit here and I'm
gonna talk about how deep we really go
with everything and as far as Indiana
Jones I think that game right there when
they said uh it's a whole bunch of stuff
I think it's gonna be a point where
you're gonna have uh the side scroller
aspect of it you know you'll see Indy
take off from the side scroll and you
know the bowler coming he's going to be
doing something or when you're driving
he's inside the car or when you're going
to the Whip and it's probably first
person mode oh I see what you said yeah
like okay so yeah I think there's going
to be multiple engines used to uh
showcase the talent stuff
uh I had teams um I I honestly think
that's what they're talking about he
literally did say mashup yeah so when
everybody's thinking um because they
don't want to say
it's a third person over the shoulder
game right where you have equal parts of
the driving aspects that they they took
time in or when Indies in a biplane and
you have the aviation mode you know uh
and they they talk to Sobo to to make
sure that they map the world correctly
you know type of things and that's that
shouldn't be taken uh as oh this is just
an add-on part to the game no this was a
very integral part to the game it's very
real flight mechanics in the game so I
think that's what they're talking about
as far as a mashup and not just want to
sing out single out one aspect of it
um
and as far as his philosophical thoughts
on it right the meaning of life like
when he says you know you live two lives
you know the question was a
philosophical question but it was a
deeper question in the meaning of
exactly what you know
um
Todd Howard sees things
before the acquisition he was leading
two lives
then when you realize there was only one
life to lead
Microsoft
this is the Revelation
so psychologically this is life changing
the question and this is because this is
the reason why the question comes up
you're trying to figure out you're like
man I don't even know why this question
would be in there because this is what
uh a real interviewer do he thieves into
the psyche of the of the man and the man
told you before Microsoft I was leading
two lives but after I realized this this
purpose this meaning yeah this this next
game is going to be his his crown in
Jewel this next game is going he found
complete utter Focus here and I'm
telling you when Starfield hits and it's
that Morrowind is that Oblivion is that
Skyrim it's that that Dragon Age you
guys you inside your hearts the way it's
gonna burn that's why I heard in my head
if you think you lonely now oh man wait
until tonight oh man because right now
if you think that feeling in your
stomach feel away oh
are you implying that a certain base
Feels Like That Bass if it's a heart is
a heart in the house tonight your heart
is stand up your heart won't be burning
you're gonna look over against the gate
you're gonna be like they having too
much fun
we ain't gonna be able to hear you
because we got that stuff real fun over
here and it's coming very soon Paul I
know if I hope it hit February I hope it
hits so fast in the new year that you'll
be like you celebrating the new year you
popping bottles and pop right in the
mouth
[Music]
come on Todd you outside let's go
outside yes
y'all went crazy with this oh no it was
good it was good to see him it was good
to see him to him talk and um yeah you
know kind of tired officially in my
opinion put to bed the whole nurturing
Studio Frederick I thought that was you
know because to be honest I forgot man
like I was there with the OG Xbox and I
remember some of that Morrowind right
what game is this this game is crazy
like the pure depth of it and to see
them you know work with console for the
first time and Microsoft help them to
get it over there Microsoft helped them
as far as you know Oblivion and stuff
like that believe it's one of my
favorite games y'all like Oblivion bro I
don't know if y'all remember how
impactful that was living was just like
again it was like apart from horse armor
right yeah that was like you play that
game like this is on a 360. and bro they
changed the way RPGs was just made I
remember remember King you know it was
so amazing to me that's when you had
like the law and the justice system in
the game yeah and you go in somebody's
house and you steal and then the cops
would be fam yeah what's going on and
you had the choice to fight Peter yeah
so that part like Dave revolutionized
the gaming attic I don't know if you
remember one of the things that I like
even when you get to Skyrim the whole
well I think that Bethesda does
excellent is this whole concept of the
more you play a specific way or do a
specific thing is how you individually
level and strengthen that to your play
style so if you like destructive match
if you use a two-handed swords you see
as you're going on you remember people
would just be hopping around sometimes
to get they jumping agility increasing
it's just certainness and I never forget
when that title screen hit
there's nothing intro yeah bro when The
fusu Rock the drag bro when you first
saw the Dragon and Skyrim and then you
sort of open plane and yo I could go all
the way over there and the thing that I
like with Starfield is doing at least
what they're conceptually talking about
is the zones right and this is the part
I love about an elder scroll type game
and a Bethesda type game is they don't
like you know I like people with dark
souls love the fact y'all can go
anywhere that right which is great
shooter shout out to Elder ring but like
that pure fear like yo what's that over
there and you not supposed to be in this
place
oh bro it's the greatest most fearful
feeling and they hunting you down oh God
oh God
the room and a giant stand up and he
decided yeah
I shouldn't have been here or you just
you got your touch you're going deeper
in the dungeon there's moments in Elder
Scrolls games and but that's the games
that and even fall out we got to get
full out it's flowers bro like I never
forget
playing doing Vats for the first time
and you like why are they coming at me
to Barbarian or I could hit the arm
knock out the weapon go for the head
shot but the percentage might be lower
but it's risky and the way and they I
like when you crack they Cranium [ __ ]
bro there's nothing like it so it's like
we're not gonna act like they aren't the
goats of this like they've been when it
comes to Modern RPGs everybody bit they
style they gave news a lot you know what
I said you made it a hotline like
they've been doing this like we're not
gonna dude made it up right but they
made it high tomorrow
they gave game developers a lane to run
with or how you do it RPG by guy like
that's cool but if you people expose
themselves because you can tell they
don't play the games like you said
because these are the things people
remember that were revolutionary that no
games were doing at the time so I love
to hear them talk about that beginning
talk put all that Purity talk to rest
and then the other thing I like is that
look you know we got to be real though
on one thing I got to be fair
he did say a comment about stuff you I
don't know I would I have to ask y'all
how y'all feel about this on one end he
says
yo Xbox hard when it's great to focus on
one console so to speak you know we
could go down the block you know what
I'm saying and get the developers the
hardware guys to really tap in he's like
the series X Series that's powerful
sheep
on the other hand he says
um you know he don't really care about
frame rates and the resolution like that
oh yeah so my question is which one is
it because as far as are we getting a
performance ball or not
because the question gonna be is let's
say this game is God blessed
and I got a couple I gotta cover for my
bad like if you don't see a performance
mode
but it's the Skyrim of the generation
I'm on PC
oh he'll play for that though I mean I I
have I have been very vocal I have no
problem going to PC for a game I care
about yeah look I'm not gonna look it's
on PC game pass so I'm good you're good
Xbox to kill you you're gonna fire it up
PC okay okay that's how you playing it
they playing you really want to play it
okay okay so okay so you got an option
or that
solved I I'm surprised I I know I didn't
think attic would be with me that is I
thought I thought we were boycotting now
I thought the attic was gonna say show
me your bills
for you I have a console for you it is
called Game Pass on PC Lord PC Atticus
we flocking we migrated not now I will
say this if that is the case on Console
mm-hmm
oh I'm not gonna call it a full L but
it's a l i mean again if the game's
fantastic
there's no around it it doesn't know
yeah there's a nail somewhere in there
the hell somewhere in there I don't see
it now open up a cake
I don't see it the reason why I don't
see it like they don't say yo there's an
option for you like go over there to the
PC and go do something you said Red Rock
was it l it was just them weird no no no
no no let's go let's go um and it has
absolutely nothing for that you know
that that 40 frames and none of that
stuff I think I think actually that made
that game Excel even more the level of
options that they were able to get I
just said it's just DLC that's all that
is okay but um this game this this is
not DLC this is the first time this week
trying this this is what we doing all
right so ain't no reused assets over
here this this is this is what we doing
this is new stuff
no it's not an L for me it's an L for
Xbox
Xbox ain't on the PC yeah
they're gonna say it was all on your
plate exclusive dudes they don't got it
anyway oh so we we not going to figure
out who's they so they if they don't
have a 60 frames per second boy is
exclusive to Xbox cost well they
shouldn't talk them they they should get
over to with attic on the PC they should
cut their mouth oh man it's about that
day then they should upgrade their
situation and be prepared for the fight
they gonna be in
the only fight I'm gonna be in is how
quick I can get home to to install it on
wherever third oh uh six different so
you know if it's no 60 you not play it
on Xbox I'm playing the hell out of it
oh I don't care about these these dudes
is frauds okay they sit there they they
capping it I I'm not gonna do this and
I'm not gonna shut up
yes you are you took it you liked it you
took it from everybody my biggest
question
now they want to be uh my frame rate
snobs my biggest question you call uh uh
King is uh or is your topic that week
gonna be
my topic
because you say whatever the topic is so
I can tell you this this could sell way
more than on what God of War way more we
could do that oh wait we do it we could
do that
since since you you fearful of me we can
do that wait wait wait now 30 frames per
second 60 frames I don't care what
frames it come out whatever frames has
come out
Game Pass games
hey let's say everybody just won't play
any Gamepad and it didn't sell let's do
that because you you got enough right
there that should be enough for you
right there taking it who taking it
anybody
picked that low hanging fruit let's go
so hold up hold up hold up you're saying
is there a time frame because I know
sometimes there's got to be okay what's
the time frame because if I don't give a
time frame you're gonna sit there and
say we'll see in the end of this right
here every 10 years
so let's do this oh
whatever time it takes right now until
star field comes out so let's say it
takes six months for Starfield to come
out okay okay
that's the six month Starfield guy
I just say we do we do so God of War
guys whatever whatever day if it drops
in November then it gonna have a whole
year
to catch up to sales if it don't and it
drop in February if it dropping January
whatever they got two months or whatever
to beat God of War that's it so from the
moment it dropped that's when the
tickets start and it stops for God of
War
so whatever star field releases let's
just say hypothetically is Jewel so from
this date from now until June that's the
stop
until June right now
we take the Talia they numbers for that
yeah and for how many months that is
then we then but we got to remember when
Starfield drop we gotta be like okay how
much did Ragnarok sell at this point
right now up until that point we gotta
write it down today okay so whatever
to that point at that point I'm giving
you all the way to that point I'm
letting you rock until it come out
um
trying to make this bet be like a year
and a half long but you know I know what
you're saying
let's just say either again
but if either game has a long tail like
elderly had a long tail so it in fan is
the king you know I'm saying like let's
say Starfield does what king says he's
going to do and he has this long tail
this is to talk at the other year people
want them you know I'm saying the
long-term numbers this is an interesting
event chat what's that thing now now uh
now these are sales right not engagement
how many frogs were thrown
a year
see I have faith in the fact that
everybody falling asleep on God of War
right now she got probably like two
percent of people that finished it
I just want I can't wait for this game
to come out and then for this game for
people to call you and tell you yo don't
make a a a video about that you know the
algorithm everybody eating up this
algorithm so I feel gonna be the next
Toast of the town in that attic hard
they said attic shook damn take that
deal addict Troy Troy addict said
addicts
these people love listening to stuff
don't like actually thinking about I'm
not making a bet that's gonna be a year
and a half long like if being serious
about the Starfield thing he'll hit me
with this 30 day right if not you know
what it is this is a real RPG digestive
battle that's kind of cute
it's kind of true attic for RPGs I'm
giving you all these holiday sales yo
why are you afraid man like right now
you got holiday sales man everybody want
that God of War man you saw those
PlayStations but here's the thing come
on man I have to wait for Star film for
that amount of time
are you gonna let me call it I have to
wait for the amount of time that God of
War has been out when Starfall comes up
so you're going to get the holidays
that these dudes don't show up when they
start to show down
I can't I got faith I got faith for the
broke dudes did this we all see I got
faith so so what all right so we are we
doing concert or console
yo Starfield man whatever you can
consume your God award that's your
business B I ain't got nothing yeah
so we're gonna take the MPD junk we're
gonna take the MVP that PC alone yeah
okay
yeah it's radioactive over here
it's not happening but look we're gonna
get them knees back
[Laughter]
out the window every time you try yo yo
what's up the knees back
running back
did you stupid anyway we moving yo they
messing with Attic in the chat y'all
fine leave him y'all leave my man
there's a reason that I have King's
knees and they don't
I slipped up they jumping out the window
the day didn't slide out you got it you
got a lucky one
addict isn't about that life he played
the flute I'm done yo come on we have
another bet on it's it's whether or not
uh Wolverine and and Spider-Man 2 will
be only on PlayStation 5 or or it'll be
a cross play and that that's the BET
right now it's like stop acting like I
haven't made other bets chat like you
guys are being too ridiculous like you
guys want me to make anything out the
door
2025 for a game that's three two years
out the way and I say yo let's do this
for now I'm not gonna wait a year
King wants me to make a bet
to come out then we have to wait the six
seven months at Starfield come out on
top of the two to three months
so then we have to wait it'll be like
like 3 20 24 before I get this thing
come out
what free it comes out in a minute but
by your logic so the deal and the bet
that we just made is contingent on
Wolverine and spiders
so I said it's only going to be on a
place
um it's gonna be on Playstation 4. he
said the thing is we don't have to wait
for Wolverine and Spider-Man 2 to come
out to know what console yes we do
we know
Greensboro had a PS4 he is right you're
talking about everything crossed gen
over there across the streets
everything is across the streets
there's two condos over there
yeah man that PlayStation 4 holding
electricity back on the fire Builder
yeah
right now we call it the full building
yo
the four bills
that's that that's that that project
that's a hood classification I can't
control that with IOP TV satellites on
top of the floor
yo brother you ain't gonna leave a
brother behind are you brother
[Applause]
yeah we'll read all by yourself
derogatory term I can't condone that
female
took the podcast somewhere else I don't
need that energy
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that's that's different
all right
hit that like hit that like myself
together because
PlayStation I was in there laughing too
hit that like I saw you all right
it was a funny joke y'all ready y'all
ready okay Lord Metro I remember for 14
months Lord silver for those interested
the street fighter 6 closed beta 2 sign
up is Live December 16th and 19th King
added you on Fall Guys salute to the
Lords and chat and Eldon ring is Game of
the Year
wow Lord
wait wait wait wait that's Lloyd what
this is what's coming up game of the
year I thought she was going to be a
Bayonetta kind of dude okay
he said no he understood what happened
over there okay uh then we got Carl
Andrews Jr five dollar super chat if
Microsoft acquired epic games would Sony
bring some silly argument that they
would lose fortnite it's laughable on
the best love uh on on the best thing
love the show thank you sir that will be
hilarious salute that they only put
fortnite with game passes
best CEO imagine how crazy it would be
if if any of them bought epic and just
yank Fortnight off the competition
everybody ain't got too much or you know
what they do they let them keep them but
they never update it so you're already
like season five constantly
you playing practice they're like yo man
did you get that new Spider-Man
oh Microsoft Store updates every six
hours Playstation Store updates every 24
hours
y'all messy you have no gym don't like
that with parody y'all yeah that's the
four building tour
greetings Lord Todd mentioned to not
take away from features they will
sacrifice graphics and speed how do you
feel sorry
we talked about it this is true you saw
the trees oh no not that again they had
the bogosh trees
the trees
[Laughter]
they should have had me in the studio
but the time what's up with the trees
foreign
Todd Howard is the disingenuous I don't
trust him I don't yo for whatever reason
I've read it that quickly I thought he
said Todd Howard is indigenous
today hit the like button disingenuous I
don't trust him okay okay
we got round remember for six months two
hours which had Xbox brought Call of
Duty and Morrowind to console yesterday
yeah they did yes they did OG talk real
ones know yeah home of Call of Duty for
real though then we got our D member for
one year two dollars to protect Cog tell
Colin to give Xbox some credit shout out
to Carla you know we disagree on that
one but that's okay
then we've got a Donald taku five dollar
Super Chat Phil Spencer is Batman
picking up orphans when they're down on
their luck and turning them into beasts
always on time always dead when he cool
always there when you come home yeah
what's up baby
scrape my knee
I got you okay
love you guys as always I know this
isn't combat talk but King his name is
Tyson Fury
the same bum that he fought before he's
the dude is literally the bum of the
British heavyweight division that goes
up and down and loses every other week
oh please
listen Tyson Fury had to stay busy it
was Contra uh
he was obligated to do so he had to stay
busy fight Joshua doesn't want to fight
him that's a shame right there yeah
Joshua is Running Scared I don't know
why yeah I don't know but yeah you know
what just you already got lost
you know get it done
um and then you know um he has ousic
next so hopefully usik really takes the
The Challenge and actually fights him
but I told y'all before
um if Deontay Wilder couldn't take him
out of there yeah there's no heavyweight
out there that's going to stop this dude
so right now there's no heavyweight on
the on on the Slate that can actually
stop him so let him just retire man yes
we got so and we got Mr too opinionated
Super Chat addict is right there's a lot
of casual people who don't know Elder
Scrolls 6 is exclusive yet just wait
they hear that song If it's a house a
heart and a house tonight
[Music]
is the two opinions to get five dollars
from chat can you say that Xbox and
Bethesda are Method Man and Mary J Blige
that's right
let's go let's go
we got Hollywood rules
wishing my NY video game cousins a great
show while I suffer watching the Jets
love you guys
so what what is this oh my god oh they
can they get Molly [ __ ] oh
no they're coming back down the Earth
the white era oh he took the screen off
no no anyway good to you then we got ham
from tsws gave me ham solo shout out to
you sir two dollar Super Chat preach
King you are the iron Minister thank you
brother uh yeah I had to get off a
camera and activated my covet when I saw
the score
yeah so yo it's twenty to six
oh no
it don't matter
26.
I think it's third quarter there we go
uh put the crust in the chat for Vault
Chaplin shout out to you sir absolutely
oh it's silver no doubt and we got yeah
baby father five dollar Super Chat yeah
I bet money on Michelle Obama's internet
that Starfield sells more than God of
War even in Game Pass
[Music]
wow that's a straight slaying son okay
we gotta get done dirty then we got Lord
Metro and going back to what he's known
for two dollar Super Chat tears of the
Kingdom will sell more than Starfield
he's backwards he's back on be back on
brand now yeah he ain't wrong though
you right as hell yeah then we got
lucious Augustus remember for 15 months
God of War Ragnarok has bundles with the
PS5 right now are we counting those
sales too yes we've done whatever sales
they can get done but we would if they
did I don't think they count those yeah
I'm I'm not going to count the returns
I'm gonna let you slide with the return
I'm gonna let you walk away with all
these Green Dot specials
[Laughter]
I'm only doing things if if I know
there's a good chance I ain't doing
stuff that that that's too wishy-washy
attic my knees go bump in the night
let's go yeah we got both Chaplin five
dollars in the chat Lord Adam got
Derrick Rose needs right yeah
they all about this is man what it is
they they they're so obsessed with me
giving King his knees back they they
that's all they care about that's right
that's all they shouldn't care about we
get my knees
good to you then we got yeah baby father
once again five dollars a pizza addict
looks like Homer Simpson backing into
the bushes
Southfield PC sales along with kilgado
you know what I didn't think about I
think about the PC shoes
look I mean you know busy guys will buy
the steam version
the reason I didn't do it is because
like I'm not gonna sit here and get hit
by oh steam gonna it's six seven months
later Steve having sales for 10 bucks a
whole nother Beast that is I forgot oh
yeah that is true
PlayStation will hold firm on sales for
a while I don't think they're gonna do
that on Steam with Starfield
[Music]
um
lame two dollars to protect anyways more
like Craig listo protocol right yeah wow
it's coming up it's coming up who's
coming up here we'll talk about it on a
Taco five dollars US Nintendo fans
understand that Elden ringing AKA breath
of the Wild's little brother is game of
the year but big brother gonna show him
how to do it next year
coming out it's that Big Lick talk
then we have Pete remember for one month
shout out to Pete Pete Todd Howard wants
30 FPS Xbox Engineers want six let's see
what happens
and we got Spartan go 17 two pound Super
Chat my man's Todd been capping since
the dawn of time though with the
disrespect of the god what holy Captain
but he capping with real championships
they got Rings bro yeah he got Rings
this is this isn't like a Peter Molly
new type situation
multiple times like what are we doing he
got both to put chips anyway yeah now we
got CW two dollars of attack lying Todd
versus snitching gym tickets oh wow they
go hard at times
man you can't come here on the home
Squad right now you gotta cut that out
yeah
that guy protected B yeah
let's go then we got round two dollars
Super Chat PlayStation 4 selling bundles
with Modern Warfare 2
um smart [ __ ] sell all the bundles they
want they got the water
[Laughter]
this is before we got a double ray Right
double ray two thousand chat with
Ragnarok count if it drops on PC before
oh okay
well there is no bending knee but that
but that that is a good one Whatever
sales up until that day that they make
this one will drop that's when it stops
that's gonna be a conversation unto
itself which would mean Starfield was
dropping in the six month range I mean
I'm sorry and I got a war drops oh yeah
that would be a crazy shot out here for
a reason is that kites yeah we all
caught up yes sir caught up all right
let's do it solve this is you the most
controversial but very opinionated topic
this week yeah certain game drop what
game is that mean ah Kalisto protocol
but our friends uh over at um what's
your what the hell they called again but
he said what the hell they call it you
mean
two videos uh published by Crafton
um so yeah this is a spiritual successor
from one of the creators of Dead Space
spiritual successor Dead Space about a
month away from the actual uh remake of
Dead Space coming out so um it's
interesting
that this game kind of for so many years
people were like we want more dead space
after Dead Space Three and then all of a
sudden you have a spiritual success to
it and lo and behold you know the Dead
Space remake is hot on the teal so it's
not going to get a lot of time to
breathe
um yeah so Callisto protocol is kind of
exactly in the same vein of dead space
and in this instance you're uh you're a
prisoner and a at a like space prison
that kind of uh gets overtaken by these
monsters you're released and you're
trying to get the hell out of there
um the game essentially looks in place
kind of like dead space where you have
like your your menus kind of pop up in
kind of midair it is called sort of like
this display that kind of pops up in
midair it's not really you going to a
menu or anything like that everything
happens in real time your um your health
is displayed kind of in the same way as
Dead Space where it's like it's it's
like a little meter on the back of your
forehead on the back of your head kind
of like uh where Agent 47 has this like
his uh QR code back there right and the
gameplay again it's it's trying to
harken back to that sort of uh horror
style gameplay the difference here
between this and game and dead space is
that it's more melee focused you do get
later on you do get some sort of you get
more more shooty shooty sort of uh
weapons but the gameplay it varies
differently in that it is more melee
focused than you would have in a dead
space
um so far I'm like two hours in so I'll
turn it over to affect in a second
because I know he has much more to say
yeah
um I'm enjoying it for what it is I have
the PC version so uh I'm not going to
talk about steam deck right now but oh
okay yeah I got it to 30 yeah right but
but I'm playing it on the actual PC oh
um but even then PC the PC version had
stuttering issues uh right off the bat
that we're talking about the PlayStation
version not having and then the Xbox
version not having some of the stuff the
PlayStation version has but on the PC
just this morning they dropped the patch
which helped a lot with the stuttering
when you go into the game initially
you'll have a little bit and then it
Smooths out
um whereas yesterday uh and launch day
it was not pretty it was not pretty at
all it was stuttering crazy
um so
I think that hurts the game in the long
term I think it's good that the game is
out before dead space I was talking
addict about it yesterday he kind of
thinks it the opposite where the the
game probably would have done better to
come out after death space and and a
have more polish and B still be distant
enough from that space where it would
differentiate itself enough especially
with the melee game plan whatnot
um one thing I'm feeling that and maybe
I'm just used to this sort of stuff and
I haven't played the game in the
environment I would like to play it in
with the lights off and you know the
headphones I'm gonna be able to play it
like that classic I feel like the game
isn't as scary as dead space and maybe
it's just me being used to it you know
um there's a lot I feel like a lot less
less of a sense of dread than I did in
Dead Space because off the bat it feels
like this prisoner you're playing as is
a lot more better or quick to handle
like you know just getting down you know
what I mean in a way that Isaac clock
necessarily it wasn't necessarily
um you sort of fall into the Isaac Clark
character whereas this from the rip
you're like oh hold on I gotta start
swinging on these dudes and it just
feels like it's not as scary to me all
in all I do think it's a good start for
something new a lot of times you know
we've seen in recent years certain
things come out one and duns we
criticize Xbox a lot for this with a lot
of one and duns and not getting like
you're not you're not these games I'm
getting chance to grow and into
something more special so I hope we get
more Callisto protocol I think this is a
great start
um there's a lot of issues with the
combat though when you talk about the
melee based Focus combat
the timing on the combat is weird
because it is very dependent on you
watching your enemies and when they
swing and sometimes it feels like even
you watching you know what direction
they're swinging at you from
um stuff like that sometimes you still
get hit and it feels cheap
like anything it's a matter of getting
used to it there's also a block mechanic
where you pull back and you sort of
block but I think in them trying to make
that feel very cinematic and less gamey
it feels like you have less control over
it at least initially right and then you
couple that with the tech issues up
front and the game
doesn't necessarily respond the way you
want it to be responding so that's
frustrating because you get to see a lot
of the hot death animations of early on
because I've seen some nasty ones but
um yeah it is one of those things where
I think that's something that can patch
and fix so overall I'm glad it exists I
like it I want to see more of it the
things that I have issues with up front
right now I think are things that can be
fixed now to make the game better but
again I what's sad is that that first
impression already you know people are
it's not a huge super long game so
people will be done with it and kind of
move on and I hope it doesn't
necessarily fall to the Wayside on
people's Radars because I do think it is
it is a good start for a potential
series it's a good game in its own right
it's just a little rough around the
edges with certain things that I think
can be fixed
um but we'll see you picked it up you
pick uh you're streaming it you know
this is a big anticipated out of you
what's your you should Vibe on Callisto
profile
I think the enemies are too spongy
I was literally counting here and
they're totally consistent sometimes I
feel like I hit people three times
they're out of there and sometimes I'll
be feeling like I'm having a boxing
match bored out of my mind hitting these
people over and over again and they're
just like bring it bring it bring it
then when you get the gun you're like yo
okay we we we we here then you find out
the gun is pretty much just an add-on to
the melee whether like when you hit them
a couple times they're gonna glow and
you could shoot off that Limb and I'm
just like
okay see what made Dead Space Dead Space
was the realism that this is this is
series like this dude come in there
acting like like he like a chat like an
ex-champion UFC fighter and and there's
not like a lot of like yeah he's ready
for battle
it's not like a lot of real like the
first time you see whatever these things
are there's not like a lot of oh God
what just happened so it's like oh we
gonna get this dude up out of it
I got you I feel like
the biggest thing that could be done to
fix this this game is just like little
patches I feel like one patch one good
patch would fix everything about this
game okay you know it needs to be one of
those things where
you could play how you want to play it
seems like they they demand you to play
a certain way like they want you to the
mayor they want you to melee and then
they won't use the guns as a second
priority this should be balanced half
and half or you can go into any
situation as long as you have the ammo
and do what you need but the May Lane is
there when they get close okay and I
feel like that's what they want they
want they want you to step in the ring
and brawl with these people okay uh and
sometimes the the camera is an issue
because there'll be multiple around you
and you feel like you can't avoid
everyone you don't have a mirror telling
you hey behind your brother
oh man oh man
you know it it's sad I would say right
now I haven't I haven't finished it but
I would say this game has done enough
to where it's like part of me wants to
tell people to support it just so
they can get that opportunity to do
another one but then the other part of
me is like
there's clear issues and I feel like how
do they not see these issues like yeah
there's a big concept I want to know
when they have testers test these
mechanics out and stuff do they even
listen to them or is it just like does
it work okay work shut up
when I'm playing something like this and
I'm just like
I just got clapped by four people
because I couldn't see two of them have
to fight and I don't see how they don't
see that that's an issue
yeah it's it's interesting right because
you know one of the discussions that
came up was that the Embargo right and
the fact that the Embargo was held super
close from my understanding into a
release date of the game and you know I
don't know if we want to go there or
whatever but I know that was a talking
point but other than that I didn't
really have an issue about the game ran
to be honest with you it ran pretty good
on the Xbox I understand where people
this this feature wasn't there that
feature wasn't that I don't care about
none of that does it run solid I did
send some frame rate drops but it wasn't
enough to make me like
like drastically like I'm sorry missing
features of the least of this game's
problem so it's running at 60 on Xbox I
felt it I felt the drop but I didn't
feel like I don't I didn't feel like a
consistent 60 but I did field draw okay
yeah
and well let's see what you guys have to
say about I know you guys haven't played
it but yeah I I know this this
controversy hey let's talk about it
what's the controversy so the
controversy is that um
as the game was was in preview or
whatever not preview but uh you know
early uh reviews from you know whatever
YouTubers and and Outlets
um there were pictures shown of the
credits as people were finishing the
game and they noticed there were like
over a hundred Stoney employees who
worked on this game
um and I don't think that's something
that was necessarily out now hidden or
anything like that but it wasn't
necessarily anything that I had heard
about beforehand so um yeah so
it's only helped uh work on this game
right and they have the marketing for
the game
and the thing about it is when you look
at the differences between the Xbox
version and the PlayStation version like
we're talking about like steady frame
rate on the PlayStation version four
building back at it again we're talking
about we're talking about Ray tracing
implemented and and not implemented on
the Xbox and it's like you know I've
heard some I've heard some
some theories on this and people like
well you know the PlayStation devs they
they know how to work on the PlayStation
and like and I'm like
they're devs period I guess they've been
working on PlayStation PlayStation at
its core isn't that dissimilar from an
Xbox you know we could talk about the
SSD and the last level you want at its
core I don't think it's that dissimilar
from Xbox it's very close you know so
I just don't yeah I hate I hate The
Conspiracy Theory stuff but this does
not if it just it's weird that like you
know you work on it obviously you gave a
little bit of a you gave a bag right
some kind of a bag you have the
marketing rights
and your version of the game is superior
at launch with a game to be honest that
in a lot of ways because this is a short
game it is a kind of an action-based
sort of narrative game The Tale on these
types of games isn't very long so if the
if the issues with the game aren't
ironed out on Xbox and PC in a
relatively short amount of time this
game you know the the small Zeitgeist
moment for the game could be done and
over with and the narrative is going to
be what that PlayStation version rocked
and everything else just wasn't and then
people forget about it move on oh man
someone has a raft so I'm not you know
I I don't know this whole situation I
I'm not necessarily I hate being I I you
know me I do not like conspiracy
theories but this is I think I don't
know man I
I understand where people are coming
from and they have every right to be
upset because it's not like a like a
timed exclusive or anything like that
but at the same time I don't I don't
like when big Publishers do this
when it comes to like this small Indie
team like who parties in the game
they're not a huge Outlet this is not
like EA doing it like Activision like to
me when I see this it's like look
they probably didn't have a whole lot of
help in terms of this and if they had so
they sold a little bit to get a little
bit more help even though it's just on
the PlayStation like I'm okay with that
I don't like the practice but it's just
how business is and as long as they had
extra help it's just like look like they
had to get that marketing deal Sony was
willing to help them sure they probably
had to do a little size how some like
look
Dorian Gray is saying that Crafton is
crafting is massive so I I don't know
the ins and outs of what Crafton has or
owns or whatever but if they are a big
publisher and just kind of or the thing
is though is just because they're
massive did they did they come out and
support this this title a hundred
percent probably not well they purchased
them recently they didn't they purchased
uh what you would call it uh they
purchased the studio fairly recently it
wasn't like
this is this is relatively new in that
regard
um so yeah I agree with you like I don't
know that they I feel you I feel you but
at the same time
part of me if crafted is that big
because I didn't know that company but
it's it's an owl they shouldn't be doing
that uh you know that I feel like people
should
speak out against it but it's a business
practice and it's like I say when it
comes to raising the prices but this is
this is where this is where the
hypocrisy comes into play when we talk
about certain statements that have been
made about a certain big deal
and this this is what gets me bro
I'm [ __ ] up I'm gonna give you I'm
gonna give you all the sausage
don't you be out here snitching man your
business but um yeah when you think
about the things that Sony has recently
said about you know that you know
Microsoft will try to you know they
won't be parody on Call of Duty and
things of this nature
that it just feels like Sony when they
make all these statements about what
Microsoft could potentially do at the
conclusion of this uh at the the term
adult got the terminal the termination
of whatever they called it
um it just feels like they're looking in
the mirror man like
and you hoping that the roaches
scattered that's what you're trying to
do I see you I see you calling me out
and I see I see what you're doing and
you're talking about parents I'm talking
about parody I'm talking about parody
here we go
disingenuous arguments Buck there's a
lot of disingenuous arguments going on
here it was the guys needed help us
a few of Good Men a few give back A Few
Good Men over there see you know just to
sure things up and you know uh all they
added in here man
are you implying that there was a parody
situation here because 150 developers
helped out on us when I send over a Few
Good Men you can't handle the truth
now what you really seek you don't want
the truth you want you rap you're
comfortable with the lies kid that but
let me let me tell you uh send the guys
over
there and we have the marketing rights
to this beautiful game his cholesterol
protocol when I'm sorry I said let me go
away let me see your bills I saw the
building the bill needed a little bit of
help so I I had 150 good men that can
get it over their line and I said uh
I didn't tell him anything different
than I don't normally say you know I
just looked him in the eye and I said I
remember where your butt is
let's read what actually happened
um so the images of the game's credits
uh Kalisto protocol highlights numerous
employees uh sent over by Sony's Visual
Arts Studio service
group and it's Malaysian team to assist
with the game while it's not unusual for
Sony to help in the creation of
third-party titles this magnitude of
assistance is not seen often generally
the PlayStation will assist them
do you think I will assist in certain
areas of game question like audio
Cinemax even lending out Hardware
software while
150 developers may seem like a lot there
may be good reason for Sony's massive
involvement the company holds the
marketing rights to Kalisto protocol and
an agreement between Sony and Striking
Distance Studios allows the former to
market the game on PlayStation this
means that most of the advertisement and
trial trailer shown in the game will be
branded as a PlayStation I mean come on
man you wanted I got the marketing
rights to this duck I don't want this
duck to look better I want it to be in
its best life
so like so I heard that there's no Ray
tracing over the Xbox
that I I send over my check for uh the
rate trace and check the ray tracing
check here on our side Claire did yours
clear I mean you got to know where to
place your Monies
marketing right
like the right to market the best
product just from the breast console oh
man I'm gonna tell you man these guys
thought they had us if they had a boxed
in and locked up till I send that 150
over there that game was looking good
until we showed up
next time
don't let the hens
of developers body why why I saw I gotta
ask this like why because you know devs
you see sometimes they help out right we
see Microsoft help out why is this level
of involvement bother yourself oh it
doesn't bother me at its core like if if
you talk about the being hypocrite like
I said okay the Call of Duty stuff
that's coming out yeah when it comes to
the timed exclusive stuff yeah I don't I
don't want to be uh dragged into that
argument bye it's it's like he said when
it comes like the timed exclusive stuff
right they say one thing about the the
Activision deal and then with the out
with the one hand and then the other
hand they're doing those practices
signing those deals
it looks like because when it comes to
like the Final Fantasy thing you don't
see me complaining about Final Fantasy
being on Playstation you know I might
say that I'm disappointed it's not on
Xbox but I go out and buy a PlayStation
I don't wait for these games when it
comes to stuff like this like look like
you you know
is Sony coming out there and they are
strategically sabotaging other platforms
of course they are uh that's how big
that's how this has always been and you
know maybe there needs to be some kind
of uh you know I don't like government
Outreach I don't like stuff like that
but it's just like
Sony's gonna keep doing this it doesn't
matter what you that's why I'm open to
to put to Xbox just yanking stuff off
PlayStations because PlayStation has no
problem doing it the other way around at
all if if the Activision thing was
happening on Playstation side
it's it's one of those things it's a
wrap but yeah they know what's going on
and I'm curious if if some of these
industries and some of these
organizations would have the same energy
if PlayStation was trying to buy
Activision the only difference between
PlayStation and Xbox for the most part
is Xbox can make deals that Playstation
only dreams of making and that will
Microsoft and I think that's the biggest
issue here is Sony knows that okay we
woke up a giant what can we do to put
that giant back to sleep you know and
they know if something like this happens
if Microsoft was blocked and they
couldn't buy this and let's say you know
everything went down and this still was
blocked entirely Sony knows that that is
the only way because what's the odds of
Microsoft trying to buy another
publisher if this doesn't go through I
would say slim to none I don't think
they would ever invest like not of that
size
and I think I think that is ultimately
Sony like end goal like they're trying
to put the monster back to sleep and if
they can stop this deal there's a good
chance that maybe they don't stop
everything maybe they still go out and
buy uh Sega or something else like that
but I think it's very it there's a good
chance that they stop with the okay we
don't have to worry about them coming
after Ubisoft we don't have to worry
about become an actor right after EA
like I think it reminds me of uh solve
it reminds me of that remember when they
was trying to put King Kong to sleep and
they put all the little all the other
little ones uh grenades around him and
he's like all right set it off and then
then he's like he's fighting he's
fighting he's not going there
it's like if this deal don't work you
gonna be that dude with the grenade it's
not going
it's just like when it comes down to it
I don't I don't agree with it but
there's only so much we can we can
really complain about realistically like
you know Xbox does their own little
things Nintendo does their own little
things but come on man these dudes is
actively paying they send a hit squad
all right this is what they did they saw
the game they know everybody talk about
the Callisto protocol oh oh remember
Aaron Greenberg sent out the Tweet yeah
that's on Xbox two type of thing you
know hey yeah we love to have that I
can't wait when it launches to have that
out there so they was like oh these
dudes gonna really do that you're gonna
really all right so they send over their
head Squad
now we don't know what was the state of
all the games up until the hit squad
showed up right
up until that point Xbox could have been
doing fantastic three look after the
fact we have some drop frames we don't
have no uh Ray tracing out of the most
capable machine
dudes and they actively looking real
good the reason the reason that I'm
excusing this kind of behavior yeah is
because it's like I said when it comes
to Final Fantasy thing they're just
doing stuff on a smaller scale
Microsoft's doing this exact same thing
the difference is is instead of running
30 to 60 frames on Star front on
Playstation it runs zero because it's
not all in places yeah but there's
Microsoft ain't doing the same things I
have not heard Microsoft sent a team
over to uh the building in the Xbox
version runs with Ray tracing and runs
better
I'm a first party credited in the
background I haven't heard of a first
party team going over to a third party
and you know whatever it is a little
different it's different it is
just the scope the scale of it we can't
talk about practices like that when
Microsoft's buying entire Publishers to
yank off yeah but that's not the same
it's not it's not the same but it's the
same practices man they they're doing
stuff for their consumers
but praise the other Microsoft went out
and bought all the Bethesda and yeah all
they stuff you have an agenda see that's
the and you spoke long enough for me to
hear your agenda this ain't the same one
person going inside the store to buy the
store is something totally different
than a dude going there and sabotaging
individual chips that you know that
you're gonna buy wow I'm coming in there
and you're gonna taint my chips and you
know I'm gonna get those chips that is a
false level of
sinistered Microsoft went right before
the games come out and said these are
hardships
if you buy the whole building someone be
going to this Walmart and now you're
saying you can't you can't come in this
building no more everybody else is good
you wouldn't know you can't tell me what
to do with it you can stand outside and
tell me you don't like my music so loud
sit on the corner and talk about you
don't like the fact that I put so much
lights in this luminators yeah but the
thing is is Microsoft they're giving you
that you know it's like look like we're
still Sony is still giving you that
option like like look we're gonna
low-key sabotage the game and make it
play time but you know what we're gonna
do like Microsoft is just not even
getting to that point they're like nah
we're not giving you the option to play
it on Playstation like we we just gotta
stop it
these dudes just vandalizing your car
and leaving a signature V like they they
send the hit squad over and it wasn't
like it was Anonymous right their names
is in the crowd
we did this to you we're the people that
did it to you you if you want to know
where to find this at meet us at 555
Petrie
took a whole bottle of car you took a
whole dealership away from my
neighborhood
you would buy a BMW and you took the
whole BMW dealership away and now I
can't get it
and you sitting there you just can't get
the flip top ones it's like you know
I've been to New York and New Jersey now
so it's like it's like the hottest stuff
from both States and then one day New
Jersey's like no we snatching now
and you are not allowed to die don't
show your face get that I get that but
at least going into it you know what the
deal is right so hey it's been copped so
we go into day one here and you expect
hey I reasonably expect all of these the
versions of this game to be honest on
par because of the third party game
right then the information comes out
about Sony's involvement and then the
next thing you know they do I wouldn't
mind if the so many developers were on
the game and they were like yo the
implementation of the of the rumble on
on PlayStation on Dual Senses crazy or
whatever
cool Sony that's a Sony thing perfect
when you tell me that something that
both consoles could do is just not
present on the other one
the power of the PlayStation
these are world-class developers and you
just badge your Xbox can do with with
because they tapped in because they can
easily do it like that we can't say that
these guys and you need to respect the
development cycle here
it's stink over here
but here's the thing we can't act like
these practices don't exist to some
degree like those snatch whole DLCs on
only Xbox or places
a game that's coming out you [ __ ] it
because you got the marketing you slid
over a squad this is different different
this ain't the same man y'all saying
they talk about oh you got DLC and oh
you purchased it no this is the same
product coming out
marketing rights and you send in a bad
referee you doing that whenever you buy
you could do whatever you want with but
they don't buy this this ain't they they
bought the market right there okay we
get all the trailers you talk about it
you ain't got the ability to go in there
and Fiddle around under the hood
we paid for better performance why don't
you say that boys
PlayStation exclusive Silent Hill
PlayStations
no but they've done content they've done
content right all right so you know what
I want so since y'all are all good with
this I
listening it's just like at the end of
the day
I would stand on the Square I don't have
a problem with it well what I want
Microsoft is since they got 16 to 20
something Studios yeah and you got a lot
of people probably standing around what
I want you to do is start setting them
out to all these third-party people and
having the Xbox versions be better let's
spread the money originally they could
do it they can choose to do it and maybe
that happens if the deal gets blocked
right all I'm saying is I'm not crying
about it because this war my thing is I
don't want the other side of the cry
when when Microsoft when I because y'all
know I'm Lord acquisition when Microsoft
buy the building right I don't want to
hear nothing right because I want
Microsoft to go buy the collector so we
can never have this problem again
exactly so my thing is again what's the
age old Street said if someone slaps you
you can't get mad at the reaction if
somebody come back with the gun and
shoot you so so if you get shot because
you was slapping people you was doing
all this wild stuff in the street you
were slapping DLC you were slapping
exclusive content and then Microsoft
said okay now what now what I'm buying
this whole thing get down lay there you
can't come inside I don't want to hear
nothing either so to me it's more it's
all good I'm not crying do what you got
to do but to me I'd rather have
ownership of the joy to me that's more
money big money I just I I'm just kind
of done with the pettiness because they
don't like that it's so petty I feel you
I get it but this is how
I feel you but they bake cannot match
Microsoft they gotta do that they got to
do you smoke too you dealing with
someone that got so much resource
they could just they could literally buy
you
like bro you got to play dirty I'm not
mad it's the game you know I feel you I
feel it's just to me it just seems I'm
gonna be honest with you
I kind of as much as I love what Xbox is
doing this generation switching it up
game pass it just feels like that
PlayStation name no matter what they do
has so much caches it does not matter
they're not seating number one they're
not seating who fought was that to lose
the last generation but this is the
thing though if you really think about
it though cop if you think about it
though there's no mercy but no I feel
you but this is the thing though you
really think about it even the 360
generation you got 360 was the most
popular right and then all the all the
negative stuff about PS3 the price
whatever eventually eventually what
happened
they redesigned the PS3 they made it
cheaper yes competition and they they
caught up and eventually the at the end
of it mind you yes Xbox have moved on
Xbox One the end of the 360 generation
wasn't as strong as the end of the PS3
generation but the numbers tell you that
the PlayStation after all that negative
press is still outsold the 360. and I
will always say this as well as the 360.
a lot of those numbers are inflated
because the the console was so good the
console was so good that it didn't
matter if your joint Red Ring like three
four times your copying it again I did
okay because I was like I can't be two
weeks without my 360. The Impossible
facts
it means that the PlayStation it just
doesn't matter bro as much as I like I
said as much as I love what they're
doing right it just feels like the
PlayStation name no matter what is going
to be number one generation that we kill
the dragon listen I don't know about
that bro I don't see it I don't see it I
think somebody got the Skyward Sword
so so my thing is this my thing is this
when you're you're still that far ahead
when you talk about Activision Blizzard
gets purchased by Microsoft and it's
still in third place
it just really feels like it's like it's
no it is their way of doing business
right Petty
this is where I gotta interrupt one out
one question no go ahead go ahead the
reason why King is right is listen
everything you're saying if the status
quo remains as it is now yes you're
right it feels like there's nothing that
can be done to overthrow that but we are
seeing Sony jump way out of character
with this oh yeah blizzard King deal
right because in my opinion of the
Reliance on this money song
right and that that's their right to use
their mouth that's what's been
successful for them Microsoft has
changed game they changed the rules to
the game so if you change rules to the
game you create a date and you create a
whole new market and now you buy the
building of the biggest and it controls
one of the biggest games right that you
was eating off of you're down seeing as
king recall the snitching and the outer
character because all what Microsoft
doing is all that stops pettiness you
can't do no more Petty if you buy the
build in a way right so that's it it's
now it it becomes oh now we gotta go
talk to The Regulators because we think
we can't survive as Gamers with this
this new model that Microsoft's about to
do if it goes through that is the whole
game that's what Microsoft's intent is
to battle them on this front because
they know as you've eloquently said
before they can't compete in this space
if it comes down to just buying right
and and taking ownership of something
right and it's something that is one of
the more dominant things and it's it's
under their new service with their new
model that is very difficult to compete
with with all the students and then one
may become one and two I'm not saying
that Xbox automatically passes them but
it won't be this Gap like that and that
now we talking as king said we got a
squabble what do y'all gonna do right
because y'all never Reliant so let's
keep it real last Point yeah they have a
Reliance on the Cinematic third person
they haven't been making multiplayer
games they haven't been really making
live service games that's where the
industry is trending as much as people
say the banker the bag of the exclusive
excuse me those ain't selling number one
number five all the time unless you have
an outlier like Elder ring but for the
most part those are not the top selling
games we've already dispelled that so
that model that they're doing versus
what Microsoft is aspiring to is in
danger period so if this happens yo it's
going to be this and now we want to see
what it is so my thing is do what you
gotta do I'm all for the fight let's see
who gonna survive let's go I'm all about
it because I know what one person is
doing one person has had enough
right and they're like yeah I'm not
gonna meet you on your turn
you fighting over here now we're gonna
drag you over here and let's see where
you at with that all that light work
that's cute you did that for years now
over here let's see what it is let's go
let's do this let's see are we bad
campus
[Music]
is crazy that's a different crime bro
they've been taking Maps
they took Spider-Man off Avengers
and then and this is why I agree with
Microsoft's doing because let's be real
hey addict you gonna attest to this the
minute Microsoft tried to play their
game rise of the Tomb Raider what
happened Microsoft what are you doing oh
my God that game is the Legacy is with
PlayStation and why when Phil we demand
you tell us what this deal is over oh
very good question there's no questions
they tried to play the gameplay it don't
work PlayStation is too dominant in its
face and the fan base is like nah fam so
now they say okay you don't like that we
did what they did okay
get to build them
get the building that that I'm not mad
you gotta they ended to win it they they
not playing the thing the thing is
is Microsoft opened this door when they
started buying Publishers yeah and now
Sony can't compete in that they can't go
in those Waters whoa so what they they
can only do what they can what they're
used to doing amping up what they've
always done this wall let's go let's see
who really gonna go and we I see what's
happening though at the king's defense
one person is doing this now
one person yo but but if we can't
survive if they do this
one person is doing this now all of a
sudden this guy is doing this
the bully okay so I to me I'm seeing it
play out let it let's see what happens
no I I completely I mean the point
you're making the points I've always
made like you changed the game and you
had to do that how to do it it's just
that again I see PlayStation PlayStation
how to make the moves I had to make they
had to give you uh a PS plus that's
something that's somewhat in the realm
of what game pass is if someone in the
realm of it
um you know they've had to make
concessions they're making multiplayer
games service based games they got to do
all that stuff it just feels like that
this this Petty small stuff is annoying
like the fact no no Final Fantasy on
Xbox is annoying like you know Final
Fantasy 16 whatever is six months or a
year of exclusivity it's annoying it is
but it's also intelligence because oh no
I don't know one thing about Sony man
they know their base they know what the
cachet is and it's not even their base
they know what the industry is going to
say right and to their credit they know
what's popping
and they associate their name all the
time when whatever's popping it's a it's
a great strategy it's dirty I I get it
people don't like they say it's slimy
[ __ ] I get it and I'm not gonna say it's
at the crew all the time I'm never gonna
say that but it's it's from a
cold-hearted business perception from a
corporate you can't you can't front on
it like they tried like you're not
pumping over here Xbox no we doing this
and we're gonna have our developers yeah
like bro like chopped cheese
and the Xbox said work all right we
coming through with all the goofy we
running you out the state you can't ever
come here
I love it let's see where it goes
yeah that's why I feel like Sony's doing
everything and they're possible if it
just think about it Sony has made
himself look so weak when it comes to
this acquisition because they know even
if there's a slight chance they can stop
it they know that would do a lot to
let's say they it's like I said they
stop it they know that'll put a huge
sure Microsoft will still have all that
money yes but as Microsoft willing to
raise that type of money again right I
mean and that's what I think that's
their attic if it doesn't go through
they're losing three bills the three
billions of fire because let's say I
told you I Jim Ryan in this damn
building told y'all so let's just say
the deal get blocked great he's like yes
now they gotta pay Activision that three
billion whatever that is right for for
the deal remember Activision got that
thing if it don't go through yeah
now you you buy yourself time because
consensus is even if they'll get blocked
Microsoft got the bread to take it to
court and easily win against ever to see
the issue is time the issue is okay damn
the deal was supposed to close June this
may go all the way to the end of 20 23
top of 2024 Microsoft eventually gets
Activision Blizzard now you gave
yourself an extra year no Call of Duty
on Game Pass we still survive a little
bit longer right and we get our our live
service now we can hit them with the BAM
here come factions multiplayer PC here
come all live sir we're more let's keep
it a book they were not ready to see
them react the way they reacted the
actors oh my God we can't survive we
can't do anything there's nothing we can
do in history of gaming if they have
this shows you me that you're not ready
to go there you need more time let's buy
Bungie let's get live service games now
you need more time this is something
that they did not see I'm gonna just
that's just about I don't have firm
evidence that's just something of that
scale yeah sure scale through them off
we're seeing an out of character solely
I've never seen to Kings right I've
never seen the bully act this way like
it is very scary so not to mention yeah
they're risking bad relations bad
relationships they're risking their
reputation they say nothing no Studio we
have can do it it's the Call of Duty you
just disrespected your entire yeah
Studios all of them they're risking like
damaging the morale with their other
students
yeah I mean they're risking damaging the
morale and to the point like I was
saying about the hypocrisy bro these
last statements they're just lies like
they're literally saying that Microsoft
is doing all the practices that they
already do right so they're like they're
throwing everything at the wall like
literally everything has to walk I told
listen this is the scary part working
do we really I I can't I can't resolve
Within Myself the fact that this deal
could be shut down by a bunch of
regulators who are aren't taking the
time to understand the nuances of what's
being told to them that's scary to me
that's super scary to me like where it's
like all of the stuff that they're
saying is literally lies and it it it's
they're literally talking about
themselves when they say that myself is
going to do this stuff but you're
praying on the lack of information and
intelligence of of a group that does not
know the gaming industry the way we do
we are the hardcore gamer they that does
not so and then again this is
Microsoft's fault for losing the
generation they weren't supposed to lose
Jim became dominant in a region where
let's be honest these Regulators don't
seem to understand when Phil got to come
over there and bring all the consoles
and show you how the X the ecosystem of
gaming works I remember that what are we
dealing with right so so that lets you
know and to his point you keep feeding
them yeah if they do this it's over for
gaming if they do this Xbox does this
it's over bro you supposed to do that
this is
worse off is gimping games hey you're
here for me
and it's it's like I said man like
they are sacrificing not even just that
they work with Microsoft and other
Regions they're what they're risking
that relationship too and it's just like
because don't get it twisted if that if
this deal doesn't go through and they
and they cause Microsoft three billion
dollars They're Gonna Fill away about
Sony maybe they won't come openly and
say it but they're Gonna Fill away and
this is the thing another thing we don't
talk about is the fact that Microsoft if
you continue to grow game pass the way
they want to grow it right the game is
to keep purchasing they don't they don't
want to keep licensing think about what
Netflix did right how much stuff on
Netflix now is a license that they
purchased for six months to have
something it's all Netflix owned yep
it's the same model applies packs and
all those others do that stuff yeah the
same model applies everything at some
point they're going to want to own 99 of
everything that is on Game Pass they're
gonna keep buying Sony isn't stupid they
know this right right so whether it
happens in little small bursts if ABK
doesn't go through or ABK and another
thing is that they know they're not
stupid ABK goes through
you're getting more purchases it doesn't
stop there so I again I understand the
business reasons for the pettiness it
just bothers me when it comes to
something like that where you it's
obvious with two machines that are
comparable in a lot of ways and it's
like let's let's do this like and then I
could see it going across Jim's desk
like yeah let's do this
bad at that because I'm sitting here on
the PC the strongest platform of the
ball [ __ ] yeah that's what that's when
yeah because I think we've seen a couple
instances where we like damn even the PC
is affected and yeah well I wonder how
that happened
we'll see how it plays out man fun
discussion
any uh we gotta get these super chats
sir yeah hold on we got a couple they
got a bunch
let me just go the last one I copy
pasted and then I'll just go to the next
okay
y'all need to chat wildly right now
we got Gerald Mack remember for two 25
months actually no it's silver oh hell
the IOP salute the Lord shout out to you
brother let's go then we got Dorian Gray
five dollars Super Chat I just want to
know why we're making excuses for
another buggy broken game same energy
people yeah no one made excuses for it
yeah nobody made excuses we called out
the stuff that needed to be called out
but this is the thing right yeah we've
talked about this constantly you can't
conflate the art with the business side
of it you're gonna tell me the people
making the art want the art to come out
buggy and broken no the business side
decided the game got to come out we've
had how many delays it's been delayed
already right yeah I think so so the
people the people making the game don't
want the game to come out in this
Condition it's just it's never the case
it is never the case that the people who
put their heart and soul into making
this game we're like yeah throw it out
there
no so to always remember that when you
want to you know die on a hill about oh
you know these buggy games they need to
stop the people making it aren't the
ones putting the game out like that they
they have people that they have to they
have Masters and the Masters say the
game gotta come out and uh that's
Masters Masters
so yeah we gotta always remember that
Dover Targaryen five dollars which I was
just streaming the game on Twitch and I
agree about the dodging yeah the dodging
is is weird
then we got Mike to another Super Chat
it's clear PS5 had priority optimization
would it be beneath Sony to stipulate
this priority as part of the contract
considering everything else they've been
doing no it would not be beneath we know
this
then we have Dover Targaryen again five
dollars Super Chat hey I've listened to
you guys since the last time you on
Podcast Unlocked I'm new to streaming
and hope to be on one day with King to
Cloud on Sony
man thank you for shut up blessings then
we have Jesus
Jim sent the team to maintain parody
y'all messy then we got Texas remember
for two months five dollars we chat Sony
on that Beastie Boys time sabotage it's
a sabotage
then we got caught then we got called
weed it's five dollars of a chance so
any practices I'm more egregious Xbox
users are paying full price for games
with less content features people hate
that BS they did it with Destiny yeah
I've been through this before this is
see this is new to a lot of y'all I've
been through this I haven't got guns and
Maps
Destiny wasn't broken on Xbox
I'm not even saying the Xbox version is
broken it's just it's not a good piece
that's it how you gonna give the PC too
the game was the game
you know what they're gonna say they're
gonna say well the reason it runs better
on Sony's platforms because they
actually have people they're
additionally helping them this is fast
yes
we got story and great about Super Chat
this isn't how it is why is PC being
screwed over yeah I can see the PC the
PC
yeah no I know attic yes yeah I'm
perfectly fine
Mr Starfield on Pizza
exception
yes
we got r b AKA The Underground gamer
five dollar Super Chat Lord Cognito what
part of the acquisition war is crying to
the rest Jim tricky disk Rock yeah
I've been on a set on a Sunday on a send
Aid to Sony tour for months yes
where's War Lucius Augustus member for
one year two dollars Super Chat the
media showed its hand with Tomb Raider
yeah I agree with that I agree yes I
agree yes if Microsoft realized they
can't do what Sony does and it's
literally was the same thing the first
time they did it they got they got
bopped through the street dragged as if
it was the most egregious thing that's
what what are the factors that four five
okay we're gonna change the rules of the
game seriously I don't like what we do
what they even in the world where that
game may not have got made without
that's what we're stepping in doesn't
matter and that's when you know like you
said sucks off Sony's dominance in the
space is is very strong and their
influence is very strong and that's what
Microsoft had to change the rules to the
game so I'm not mad at either thing
and we got Jesh again two dollars anyone
play the dollar store Dead Space Jesus
a lot of potential I want to get the
patch right at it yeah it's not even
just a patch like I feel like the
gameplay just some some patches on like
the actual how the game actually works
not like any of the performance or
anything like that it's like I feel like
you know like I said like I used I feel
like I I I I was fighting some dude in a
ring for like 10 minutes sometimes like
and when you put multiple in the same
scenario then they have like a a generic
stealth system in the game like yeah
it's just little things like that that
kept adding up that made did you guys
see Maximilian Rage Quit oh no wow yeah
and he don't race quick games like that
oh wow yeah but but the sponge stuff
that addicts talking about is true
because you remember like old res evil
residual one where you didn't really
know how many shots yeah
until you hit you hit him one time and
and the head exploding like oh I got him
yes it's like that where you can't
really tell you can't really tell when
I've I've had fights where I've cut off
both their arms and they still coming
and I'm like wait a minute well you can
get rid of their head and they'll still
come after you oh wow yeah so it's like
it's cool but it's like again it's one
of those things like you don't feel in
control at all yeah play dead space and
then we got called and leave five
dollars in the chat Microsoft is a
threat the more competitive Xbox is the
more difficult and expensive it will be
for Sony to get these exclusivity and
marketing deals what's your man said
um what you call them a young Odin
let there be confidential competition if
it's about competition let us have
competitions man everybody's playing and
that's where I think that Sony cache
just comes in because sometimes it feels
like there's certain companies like
we're not messing with Xbox no matter
what you gotta make great games you got
that that you got no choice in a minute
they're using bass yeah
Xbox so we want the game pass back we
want you to to Port it we want you to
pay for that too we also want you to
give us the money that you would have
potentially made on your platform and
we're also going to take the money from
your platform that you sold it for
now I wanted to make the PlayStation
version better I honestly really feel
like a lot of the stuff that doesn't
come to Xbox is low-key extorting like
they want to hold off to make more money
from them in the long run well some
companies will double dip oh you know
the sugar daddy got extra money
get your PlayStation back then when the
Zeitgeist and I said this one Duke then
you go get a while it's still here
yeah because when that PlayStation going
you ain't gonna get nothing from over
there and that's the thing when you go
over the Game Pass afterwards it has to
be game pass because you're not gonna
have a second Zeitgeist moment selling
it piecemeal right it has to be game
fast at that point stick it on the
platform
we gotta miss the two opinionated five
dollars of attack people
damn it Xbox fight back Xbox bet people
oh my God
I don't want to hear not like that I
don't want to hear anti-clamp petition I
don't hear nothing let's go
uh so you heard it first Cog just want
bodies listen I'm for the wall I'm for
the squabble let's go
baby yeah let's go outside the Mulberry
stepping over all the bodies he gets to
the end and he throws the throws the
little uh paper towel and he's like okay
when they announce ABK ABK was announced
before that before Bungie right that was
yeah so see that that kind of swing back
shoe not like oh rage Spacey is going to
be here with pigs talking to somebody
that cares
Drago Ivan Drago if he dies he dies
[Laughter]
remember all that you're talking
about
don't cry don't I don't want to hear
nothing all right let's go
get his hands on you he got them
like Bill Spencer had a conversation
with Sony y'all hear you trying to get
stuff like Starfield and stuff like you
know let's stop with that yeah like Phil
Spencer you go home you know we ain't
talking to you then he comes back with
the bank we bought the building son he's
like all this crying all these people
crying about and all of a sudden it's
anti-competitive in first place they'd
be like yo who that dude is that's your
opponent don't shake hands and you know
what's crazy
too sure I will say Sony hasn't bought
nearly as much as Microsoft but they
have bottle-offs
yeah the Acquisitions
the only difference between the two is
Microsoft is buying more bulk and Sony's
buying like cherry picking certain
Studios that will work only shopping at
the Dollar Tree while Microsoft is
actually shopping at Gucci Gucci
friendly products he's stupid don't do
that
I picked up I picked up this loose
Raider blade 2000 which Idols didn't
want anything to do with Tomb Raider
until Xbox yep for whatever reason there
was really uh keen on doing the rise of
the Tomb Raider so um
then we got hold up I got something to
have my boy back in here
this ain't this ain't new Sony this
ain't new Sony's been planting bushes
all over the place making developers on
a parody making developers on a parody
parody clause and more their green
thumbs be glowing listen gentlemen I
love y'all punctuation please listen
what it is you only have certain amount
of characters so you know those
punctuations they add up in characters
the fun thing about the fight is we're
seeing both sides tell what the other
side doing and I was like yo they
blocking Game Pass
whoa that was funny when that came out
like yeah you can't put it on camera yes
you can go outside but you just can't go
in his house he can't pump none of that
game pass over here B I don't want you
over there on his lawn get off as long
I like this one it feel good
then we got free R Kelly five dollar
Super Chat I'll wait for Callisto to
come to Game Pass whoa disappointed
about the release I love survival horror
yo all Kelly did the greatest heal 180
like this is that's what happens when
you send over that care package
I send over 150 Developers
I'm like yo he's a c76
over that mod eight go set them straight
message
and we got chicken J chicken J member
for 16 months Lord bronze Dead Space
remake for the win okay I mean guys
don't discount this game like really
like this yeah I think trying to kill
this in the womb man like come on that's
why I said I felt like it would have
been better coming after Dead Space so
people actually had that fixed because
you got so many people hyped up for Dead
Space they see anything remotely
negative about Callisto I told you yeah
been a 10 like to really like have its
own space and now and the sad part is if
if they would have like made the game
pretty much a dead space rip-off or a
dead space clone we will what
conversation will be at well you know
it's a fun game but it's like dead space
so it's just like they they tried to do
something unique and I don't think it
was like it made no mistake it looks and
smells like dead space all the way
through it's just the melee stuff like
Yeah and I don't think that what they
did is a bad thing it's just like little
patch things that you know making the
people uh be hardcore you know they
sponges stuff a little stuff like that
and they can easily fix that I feel like
the game would fill and play completely
different yes yes
that's particle 17 2015 PS living off
DLCs before Xbox chokes them out wow
messy today yeah
guys I'm violent violence
there we go we got stitched the five
dollar Super Chat Rock Jim Ryan Hey the
door to building four is locked security
Phil Phil got the building and changes
the locks right oh yes
the moment they found out was locked you
know normal people okay they bought it
man you know I get it Jim Ryan it's like
someone called a cop
Jim went inside the building said um the
Wi-Fi password seems to be changed yeah
yeah get over service
[Laughter]
all right then we have free art and
Kelly again five dollars for chat also
Callisto flopping makes me worried for
Dead Space remake Silent Hill 2 remake
and Resident Evil 4 remake damn remakes
on top of remakes
if
yeah Silent Hill 2 we'll see is blooper
we'll see and I think Callisto will be
fine in the end too exactly it's
basically what you said it sounds like
just a couple of patches for some key
things yeah you got to understand if
they want to bring back these these
series you have to reintroduce it to New
Gamers you don't you can't just jump off
and and be like you know res evil did it
right with res Evil 7 but it was that's
very first person it was very right
people don't realize what like what
capcom's done with the Resident Evil
franchise but Sony did God of War these
are like one in a hundred things yeah
people do that very effectively yeah
that's hard to pull off so hard to knee
ten dollars to the chat okay we got some
jobs every game we talking about
always looking out always looking out I
got three of those two games
we got a Callisto protocol code we have
a Need for Speed Unbound code Global
code and we got midnight Suns Legends
legendary edition
man brother what you do for the
community is tremendous we appreciate
you man such a good dude man shout out
to him man absolutely absolutely hold on
let me see if I missed anything John but
I know that was the last one all right
we're probably moving on we gotta get
this thing going uh Kings you can set me
up Sir
King wants to discuss what is going down
obviously uh Black Friday situation you
know what I'm saying Xbox series X
dominates Black Friday sales this year
Microsoft console alongside the Nintendo
switch dominated the holiday season and
it says it uh beat the sales of even
merchandise toys some character called
Bluey I don't know what Bluey is but um
Bemidji takeaways is that yeah series X
topped the Black Friday sales chart this
year with Call Of Duty Modern Warfare so
that's it Microsoft Modern Warfare 2
selling so well well alongside the
series X probably an effect of the
Microsoft Activision potential blizzard
acquisition and then um they did this
despite obviously Playstation still
having the rights and then there was
also a little tidy said the PlayStation
had the rights to Market it yeah they
still can't do yeah it was definitely
definitely not Black Friday Christ yeah
definitely uh the The Talk of the Town
as far as Black Friday and uh yeah just
being the most sold product during that
time so that's that Black Friday right
oh I know what this is okay so this is
for you for attic let me let me let me
tell you what was going on in the
background okay what was going on
nurse
[Laughter]
nurse uh did the anesthesiologists come
in and administer the anesthesia
yes he's he he's he's he's out doctor
all right do they have the proper forms
did he did he sign the forms the bet
it doesn't seem to be a signature here
what do you mean there's no signature
where he signed his knees over
um
[Applause]
because I didn't do it
get inside his knees over through the
procedure
oh you had these ready get the lights
cut the lights we we were we were fit to
go in yeah
[Applause]
I was coming sharp blade at all
you had him you had them you had him he
was gonna line up my boys tied up and
locked down baby all you need to do is
sign those knees over to me boy man you
new boy you knew that Black Friday
that Black Friday crack a lacking boy I
told you young Phil ain't playing he
knocking dude straight out Friday came
he said see you at Friday man you ain't
gonna
he woke up on Cyber Monday I'm still hot
yo pretty impressive the fact that he
said you don't hit that hard you're
stupid yeah if I didn't get from Call of
Duty that's crazy so this is a two-part
joint right um the fact that um I'm
running around here you know giving my
uh
[Music]
dude
winning Black Friday no you got that
better than you yeah no one wouldn't
smoke with you and we left you alone
because you called you called you called
us Facebook go out there and do this um
but I had a bigger thought and this is
a crazy thought
let's say the ABK deal goes through
let's say Sony gets concessions
both Jim and Phil can walk away now
um
Phil can walk away
on top
he got the biggest deal done
in gaming history
and under his leadership they went from
two Studios to 20 something Studios
started Game Pass
made Microsoft and Xbox
relevant in a gaming space Oh that's
factual
he's he's gotten Awards on top of awards
on top of awards right so you're here
now this is where you are anything
unless you can just drop from here
because you're here
on the same side of the coin
Jim has made Playstation profitable
he's walking off of consolidating uh
some dead services and making it a
profitable service
he's come off of the most successful
PlayStation generation which is the
PlayStation 4 generation
and locking in and blocking up some of
the deals for ABK and making PlayStation
viable for years to come because of his
intricate
detailed snitching
and how he did it but again
he could walk out on a high right now
I was the dude that set y'all up to be
relevant to continue to win and we
started up all these uh service games
and he can leave on a high too because
let's say this the ABK deal goes Call of
Duties and Game Pass and this is the
last generation of the PlayStation here
we go you want to get out before the
wrecks it's so good yeah it was so good
and then we caved right okay but then
also with Phil Phil wants to get out
because this generation he could set it
up to win and pass the Baton to somebody
else to continue to finish that race
okay okay I'm just thinking what do you
see happens as a result of the ABK deal
do you see is the end of an era of these
two Titans slugging it out with each
other and both of them can claim victory
on a successful pass ABK deal when
concession for Sony mmm it's a good one
it's adequately
uh I don't really
I don't see either one of them leaving
yet I think we I think Phil and uh Jim
Ryan got a probably the rest of this
generation I I think I think
Phil isn't the type of person to leave
while the ship is being repaired uh and
I don't think he's he he's just gonna
leave the moment it's done I think he's
going to sit around for a little bit and
make sure it's on the right course
okay what about Jim
uh it depends on what you I don't know
about you know I I think Jim
Jim seems like he's got an ego
so I think that might keep him around
but you know we got to see exactly
how the PlayStation does in like the
next two years especially we got to see
what happens after the Activision bill
you know um see exactly
what's going on after that Activision
deal and I think that's when you can
really find out where Jim stands because
if you know they start losing Jim is
only going to leave
either when the generation's over and he
succeeded or he's gonna leave
when they start losing massive market
share
I don't see either where one of them
happening like I I think for the most
part
you know he's going to be around for the
generation I do Phil might leave right
towards the end of the generation but I
don't see him leaving anytime soon
either now as far as like people under
them like Aaron Greenberg uh Sarah Bond
they might leave
uh and move on especially Aaron
Greenberg he's been there forever but
you know I I don't know it just depends
you know Executives leave all the time
and there's too much of an emphasis on
mystery to know if One's Gonna Stay
around or not just because they did
something successful
okay not fair enough soft to the
question and the Black Friday situation
and then obviously who leaves who stays
between Phil and Jim
yeah Black Friday I always remember I
was with King about uh you know the s in
particular winning Black Friday the fact
that there was so much love shown to the
ax is really heartening like and because
it is it is you know it is the premium
console it still was 500
um so to see it moving like that it's
it's kind of is very cool you know I
don't I know they don't I wonder how
they got the numbers because for me I
always just thought they didn't
separation
so
so that's I mean that's awesome to see
because again I just for me I thought
the S is the one that's gonna far
outside in the longer term I still think
it will be but it's cool to see that
people are you know excited and still
you know interested in that in the
series X yeah um the Cod thing is like
that that's something because the thing
about it is
the average gamer the average consumer
does not know what's going on with ABK
correct I just don't so it's not like
they they're kind of heading for the
hills early you know what I mean but
like you know what let me make the
switch now like it's not it's not that
so what is it but to me it's Game Pass
it could it to me that's where the S
steps in right and I feel like the S is
like okay look I'm not buying uh maybe I
already have a PlayStation whatever I
like whatever the ecosystem is on Xbox
whatever it just it does feel like that
is where the S is sort of pushing that
Call of Duty Bundle forward
um again don't know but it just seems
that way because it would be weird that
just the average consumer Casual Gamer
is is making that migration already
because I don't feel like they would
know or care about this sort of stuff
and they're just going to play where
their friends are are already so that's
interesting that's interesting for sure
no Absolutely I'll jump in yeah the same
kind of thing like I'm gonna be real
like I wasn't sure like I knew that they
were in position as far as Black Friday
is concerned but you know what I was
like yo Ragnarok she doubted the Swami
man I didn't doubt you I didn't I didn't
need eight percent right all the time
listen I gotta eat that you definitely
you stood on your square with this you
said that they were going to do it knees
and he ain't gonna give him up I think
it's even more impressive that it like
someone said that it wasn't the S yup
that says something different to me like
okay people went out on Black Friday and
they got the X they got the big boy even
though the S had the reduced cost and
the price people got the big boy then on
top of that you're gonna tell me you're
gonna get Modern Warfare with Xbox
doesn't have the market right so I gotta
slightly push back on so I'm only the
sense that
to me that means that the Activision
Blizzard King deal is making mainstream
news
to the point where people are
associating Xbox with Call of Duty again
and the deal is not final that's
different so now it's like you're almost
changing design guys ahead of schedule
where nothing's finalized yeah it's big
the Bottom now granted it's a small
sample we got to see how it settles out
kind of thing but that's very
interesting as far as
King's question this that's tough man um
who goes first who stays
the way I look at Phil you know he's
he's course corrected
let's be honest one of the worst
Generations he was handed a
fall intensive purpose of sinking ship
and the the reason why people don't
understand I see why like people like
why does Phil get us but what did you
produce what is you know where the AAA
games and I I get that to some extent
but a lot of it to me is just Hyperbole
and people who are not in the ecosystem
that don't know what they talk about so
to me
when you had a platform that was on
death bed
that the top level did not believe in
they shouldn't even invest in gaming
we've talked about the sort of RP
numerous times and then he comes in gets
a seat at the table his his vision his
game pass from what I'm hearing him and
his team they bring this to the table
you get the higher up to now invest in a
financially lucrative situation and on
top of that save gaming then on top of
that he's a gay but a true game itself
no one can doubt that you know what I'm
saying so now you Spirit had this whole
thing you got the investment
I see him staying
for this generation definitely because
of the fact that
a lot of these deals we hear Ninja
Theory obsidian Bethesda don't get
clothes that Phil's not in the room we
hear that period Phil is the deciding
factor if Phil wasn't there yo I don't
know y'all we don't know Microsoft's
history that's the talk it's on record
this is not Fanboy stuff this is
literally people saying if Phil is not
there we were doing it we were not
signing with Xbox games Studios even
with Minecraft right so now to me that
puts him in a position he's got he and
then remember Not only was he the head
of Xbox game so he is now he is the CEO
like of Xbox that's a whole of gaming so
now he's created a whole division for
them to actually be believing and now
we're seeing that the last interview he
did he's getting marketing right so it
showed me that they didn't even have
proper marketing allocated for Xbox in a
way they would just decide thing that
Microsoft does in office and all this
other stuff so he's changed the game so
the The Vibes even he may want to retire
right now like it would be the ultimate
guy but again yeah no no I I just I just
don't because I didn't answer that I'm
sorry I forgot I didn't answer that part
but I don't think you gotta understand
like he CEO of gaming now yeah the
entire identity of Xbox is now tied to
this thing that he brought to the table
man it
for him to leave he has to leave he has
to be sure that the person is that's
going to be there in his stead right is
someone who is on board with that
thinking otherwise they could they could
topple the whole thing and be like you
have to be be honest with you I wouldn't
be surprised if there was a like look
Phil we we believe in you but if we if
we invest this kind of money I'm gonna
need you to be around so right right he
could be tied to it because we like we
did hear
um rest in peace
um the the owner of xenomax right yes he
before he passed away like this was
critical Phil being there like the deal
does not get done this is the things we
hear this is on record so I I think that
yeah maybe long term there is a plan but
I just don't see him leaving any time
he's so tied into everything right now
you know what I mean so unless there's a
continue pair like golf a bit something
happened this how old are these okay
something physically I have to now move
on but I think he's still going to be
there post-generation Jim is interested
in me yeah because Jim
I know Kingdom like this he'd been
squabbling too yeah and he was a young
Pope let's see he the one that picks up
the dirt and blows it in your face
listen PS4 what they've done in Europe
has been outstanding that last
generation and he did something I
thought would never have this is Jim's
greatest accomplishments to me
so getting the shift away from Sony
Japan
to Sony EU to me is just like a
japanese-based company now focus more in
Europe in the states is like bro what
you had to do in that board room and to
generate that level of Revenue to now
let's be honest you sir
Bladen and move Yoshida and like you
Dave's given you the keys where the guys
who were the traditional Sony gamey guys
were now demoted and they're kind of
like you can't even speak about that
this is Jim's joint now yeah and he's
different he moved up I know a lot of
people don't like him but he he's got it
they ain't got time to play games he
focused on me yeah I mean that that
changed yeah that change had to happen
because Japan just is in console Centric
anymore that sucks so bad that yeah he
was the one who came in and essentially
killed Sony in Japan but the bread yeah
you put the final stake in it for sure
yeah the Brad says what the bread says
the revenue and they're doing they're
doing great so yeah but what happens
when a a fan base loses the identity
that they so uh woven into their their
their their their DNA the key the key to
your question is going to be there is a
part there is some level and I've had
this conversation with Colin before and
this is we actually agree here which is
PlayStation has they're going to go
through a transition themselves
and because they're so invested now in
Live service and then what they're about
to do launch service is very difficult
you you may not have bagger Banger
Banger with live service
so there's going to be a shift there and
the traditional Sony fan that loves
those experiences when though not that
they're not going to exist anymore but
when there's that shift how is that
going to be received and then also the
Remake mentality that Jim is on
Jim is on no no these are bangers we got
to keep remaking this and we're here in
the rumors of the horizon
uh what you call it um
being remade again we just heard we got
incredible sources you know I'm saying
that me and Collins talked about so
we got to see that there's still risk
with them there's they're still not like
oh my God it's just all the way through
now as far as Revenue as far as you know
getting the bag and people don't like
the practices he's he's killing it you
know I'm saying so it's gonna be a good
one I if you're gonna put a gun to my
head with him
maybe him next Generation because I
don't know how old he is too okay I
don't want to be respectful I don't know
you look like an older gentleman so I
don't know I don't know that's my only
my fear is just like how old is he like
I don't know
yeah yeah I see him I see him leave
definitely even before Phil but I can
see him leaving just because to him it's
just another job like it's not all right
he's not emotionally tired he's not
emotionally tired to it at all he's
there to make them that money you know
understand the industry as much as he
needs to to be able to make the chat is
saying just younger than Phil okay no
thank you yeah I don't know what I
didn't know and look again he may be
around I like I said I'll be he right
now if that is the case
then uh if you put a gun in my head did
I say they both definitely through this
generation he's 53 years old he's 53 and
how old is Phil I don't know I'll find
out right now
because you know they said that you know
I don't know who said that oh he's
definitely younger I don't know
why you probably telling it B I don't
know let's just do it though it is a
good question to ask how old is uh Phil
Spencer
I'm kind of curious to Phil retired who
do you think takes over you know the
queen is available he's been he's uh 54
years old who's 54 a year a field so
Phil is older yeah yeah so look respect
your elders look look we do know
Sarah bombing on all them trips
and how to move how to talk to certain
people yo he's like this he's cool he's
over there notice who took it uh listen
Japan
listen Japan
um I love you and I'm I'm break some
news to you
um Phil's over there and and he loves
you too I don't uh Playstation has given
up on you the Microsoft is that you're
viable and you still have life so Japan
I want y'all to get behind this message
and I want y'all to you know all go out
and go get an Xbox
this is my message to the island of
Japan
I don't think in the show that uh where
true game is really play I'm done
I don't think uh
as long as the Activision goes through I
don't think she takes over because I
think she I think they're going to give
her to Activision she's going to take
over activation I would clean up
I would be a yeah
public relations with I will say that
yeah as well I think gaming in a skill
set that makes the most sense because I
think she's gonna go over there and then
under her is going to be Bonnie Ross
eventually the whole body comes back yes
I think I do backflips
with the situation no no no because she
was never disrespected thrown under the
bus or rejected you know um at the same
time she was able to have a level of
respect you know in and out of the
situation from her peers and her
colleagues so I thought that was handled
with class and dignity
um throughout the board so I don't know
man but I would I would love that I
would love that it's a good question
it's a good question but that's all I
got
blizzard you know what I'm saying oh
yeah
[Music]
over there hey Mike slide over 15
shopping holiday included the series X
they literally said yeah
yeah continue we have some chat that's
it
attic Magnus you man what's going on
Monster Hunter something happened what's
going on yeah Monster Hunter rise is uh
it's been an exclusive on uh switch for
a while uh I haven't played it because I
don't play those type of games on the
switch
um but
it does look like it is coming to the uh
to uh to current platforms it's going
off of being exclusive and not only is
it coming to PlayStation 5 and Xbox and
I think PC it might already be on PC I
don't know but it's it's gonna be in
Game Pass day and date
I feel like this is the biggest game
they've ever gotten Game Pass besides
the show
and uh that that's it's really big and I
think that uh that is a huge gift for
them
jump in there what are we feeling okay
you sound like you're ready oh man
listen man wouldn't that come out
January what yeah January 20th um what
what the top of the year can you feel it
that's how you start off the year that's
a big body Banger right there that is it
that that is a huge game
all right here we go here we go I think
man when I saw this I said your attic on
to something man yeah and I said Game
Pass
hey man I think there's a reason it was
in gameplay
is so good in Game Pass and it brought
up their uh Their audience so much that
they're willing to take that kind of uh
you know risk taking that off of uh
selling day and date and putting on game
pass because they know that look it's
like there's going to be a lot of people
playing I think that's that's their goal
yeah they've already made the money for
this game I think their point now is you
know obviously bring more money in but
also to bring more attention to the
brand man go track down some dinosaurs
yeah I'll jump a little early
um yeah it's a big deal it's a big deal
monster hunter's um fan base is is huge
you know you're gonna get the 4K 60
treatment you know what I'm saying so
that's good Steve's gonna get it um a
little disappointed on one thing though
I just got nothing to do it with a Game
Pass per se but no cross play don't
cross save oh man but that was
interesting so they kind of protesters
for Xbox and everybody else
to figure out what's really happening is
that company based in Japan
I told you Japan listen Phil loves you
listening says performance from
performance free from the switch 4K 60
supported on with 3D audio and then also
dual sense adaptive trigger support all
places seventy dollars one right
oh that's weird okay
[Music]
they come out the same day with an extra
Rumble
look it's a huge game I I am I am
shocked I I wonder if this listen this
is a huge deal with I wonder how Sony
let this go
for Capcom
so like there's been a reason that
Microsoft has been so quiet when it
comes to Game Pass games because this is
the first year that they they haven't
really wowed me with Game Pass games
going in there in day and Day date and I
think a lot of that has to do with
Activision I think they're trying to
appear as weak as possible you're not
trying to give Sony any leeway
whatsoever to cost them three billion
dollars but what's what's ironic is they
announced that's coming out next year
and I'm like oh that's convenient it's
coming out after the deal would neither
be in court or past like
yeah no it's huge and again
Gotta Give My Fat myself for the bet I
told y'all did the field going over
there never gonna do that in Japan and
it's wasting energy and this is why
boots on the ground when you see them
there and now every time we see a little
Dent here oh wow whoa long day day a
game Souls Co-op oh wow Capcom playing
nice oh wow persona's playing that like
it's slow it's gonna be a process but
they doing it they slowly getting stuff
on this is a huge deal I've never seen
Capcom play nice like this with Game
Pass like I asked that the attic's right
it's huge huge like that is a big deal
I'm curious where else this go yes you
know what other games
what else
hadouken oh don't you do it
can't solved what you doing
I mean it would be the ultimate I think
I think I have to keep that t-shirt I
will say this song bro that would be the
ultimate Petty clap back versus yeah
performances listen Petty for pet I like
Petty for petty go petty petty petty for
petty yeah I kept it off
sf5 was very much their attempt to go
all the way into Esports and forgetting
about the Casual Gamer that loves Street
Fighter
um bro what better way to get it to as
many people as possible is putting it on
game passes what the bag let will be
required it will be a bit okay let's
remember those let's still remember they
still remember Street Fighter is still
fighting games relatively okay
I see where you're going you still want
to get as many eyes on that game as
possible and the fact that the game is
now built for the Casual Gamer as well
as the hardcore monster hunter is a huge
thing Monster Hunter monster hunter is
the best selling franchise
for them to get it on Game Pass is huge
and I and I think the idea and the
thinking behind that is it's now at a
point where it is able to really get
people's eyes on it in a way that it
maybe a year two years ago it would not
have been Street Fighter to me is the
perfect if you want Street Fighter 6 to
come back in the same way that Street
Fighter 4 came back in this new job
service multiplayer okay exactly you
Game Pass sounds really really good it
will be a bag oh my God because
everybody everybody's loving everybody
everything I've heard about Street
Fighter 6 is is love Capcom gonna come
out
is the bag is a bag it's I don't think
as big as the bag it's I don't think
it's as big of a bag as what they gave
for Rice I don't think so okay okay
um so yeah that so rise is their biggest
friend it's Monster Hunter their biggest
friends monster hunter is a past Street
Fighter
I bet you world probably sold more than
all Street Fighter so ridiculous the
monster hunter is the king then okay it
is I'm out of the Capcom day type of
stuff this is different this is
different different yeah so uh to me
like you said Japan is talking yo Japan
yeah nice yeah they're playing they're
playing nice in general Capcom playing
nice in general they're in a position of
power too where you know a couple years
ago they could have been purchased by
just about anybody you think that was
the Kojima effect
could you be [ __ ] in one way
like you know because all right so Japan
used to go through stages of standing
next to the cool dude my model extended
to uh uh Moses type figure right you
know if he's if he's standing next to
him yeah then you you it's like you in
the 40 40 club
you're picking his brain for EF Hutton
type knowledge right right that that
type of thing
kajima seemed as that Rebel uh yeah dude
cigarette smoker I'm not saying I'm just
talking about legs up you know cowboy
boots and philosophical thing and he's
sitting in the room and I could see
everybody listening to him and if you're
associated with that dude like who you
associated with the cool dude domino
effect I know where you are and I think
that Capcom looks over and like yeah man
they're over there with kochima again
yeah they was here all week and they was
then they working with him
we need to work with them we're gonna
let Kojima get all that light let's get
over there
we did good in Game Pass
surprise though because I mean I didn't
know it was going to Game Pass so I just
knew that it was coming to Xbox and I'm
like damn date that's great within
itself
Game Pass that's a whole different
number right there the only reason why I
pushed back and I still will say
probably not I hope I'm wrong that would
be fine when she fight it's just that
because technically Monster Hunter did
ex rise did exist already
is that like it's out for everybody new
for the first time switch did happen it
switch had it and they saw well PC had
it and it's so well right but there's a
lot of people who ain't playing on
switch and there's a lot of people
always playing on PC I just my thing is
with with day and day on a street
fighter because then you literally could
kill the other sale you can't announce
that you gotta out ride oh no yeah you
gotta be it's got to be the last the
last week like you can't you can't cause
people gonna be like Oh I'm canceling my
pre-order you don't say I'm go over here
but you can't you can't
bodies you want bodies though I mean but
if you want bodies no no if you if
Microsoft won bodies are they is The
Game Pass third party budget are they
willing to blow down I don't think
they're willing to not for that that's
what I'm trying to say I agree I agree
with you Alex tags and body bags I think
dudes first of all this is end of the
year money yeah again y'all not looking
at it you gotta look at it
right that's not the beginning of the
year that's still the end of the fiscal
year of the business oh okay I see where
you're going right right yeah this is a
fiscal year end of the year yeah man
that's a dump too and another thing is
yeah
I think I think any fighting game would
be a boon in Game Pass and and the movie
that would be even more don't you do it
don't you do it so the pettiest of them
all don't you do it
bro I know where you going you know what
that's why I'm watching game awards on
Thursday because that Tekken
announcement coming as far as just being
in Dallas but I know where you're going
I know it that would be the pettiest of
all movies
but I mean again I just think I think a
fighting game in general I think Sunny
will fight you dead in the street listen
I would agree to all of this
under one condition
they go Scorch Earth Game Pass if they
get blocked if they get blocked you best
believe 68 Billy gonna be playing around
somewhere they're 68 really gonna be all
over this place yeah
but you bet then but right now I mean
they still could do it it's not like
it's out of the realm of possibility
shout out to anime compilations it
describe it's been announced the stripe
is coming to Game Pass oh yeah that's
right I forgot about that yes drivers
come to Game Pass I think
I I know you guys are probably going to
disagree with this and I know I'm
looking for more of a brand thing I'd
rather than take all that money and fund
a Killer Instinct than get stuff like
temporary game fire I'm with that
because what's what's what's better than
getting someone else's stuff is at home
make your own and it goes back to the
whole point they want to own pretty much
everything that is on Game Pass so at
some point I I definitely see them
building up some kind of team to go back
to a fighting game right whether it's
color interesting or something else
whatever
um but yeah they definitely they
definitely need that name yeah buy
everything buy everything yes yes
the Xbox the home of checking oh my God
homotech and spiral Crash Bandicoot
let me see we got a couple we ain't
nothing crazy hold on a second we got
the rubber knob five dollar Super Chat
oh no this ain't no but big felly a big
Philly ain't even unlocked his special
round round two fight oh man oh man then
we got it was anything else nope that
was it that was Metro before that but
Lord addict where can I find people find
you what you got going on sir
find me on YouTube at uh Lord addict IOP
on Twitter at lordy on the YouTube
channel I'm going to be releasing some
videos this week uh sorry I was M.I.A on
everything dude I I for like two weeks I
could there ain't no way there I'm I'm
still debating on if I want to do the
Pokemon review because I have like half
of it done but at this point I think I'm
gonna just make a video on what I don't
like about Pokemon I think I'd probably
be more efficient I hate these Rings
because no just like me what's actually
going to do better for the channel I
just don't see a review doing anything
at this point so you know I'm gonna
collect my thoughts and like you know
because people want to come at me like
crazy over my Pokemon thing so you know
what you're going to get a good 15 to 20
minute video explaining why I don't like
some and then and then if you want to
continue to go at me at that point the
comment section is there baby you can do
it right there
attic F Addington the third uh Callisto
product I'll review will probably be out
next Sunday
uh currently at the moment
you know how that is that's uh yeah uh I
I've been enjoying it though I can
honestly say that I've been enjoying I
see the fact what you said was important
to me you were like yo it's not that far
away a couple of bug fixes and then this
thing is still being it really is yeah
yeah all the stuff that really has
issues with can be fixed yeah that's
what's up it's in the game they could
fix it right now it's not the foundation
like right right that's why like part of
me just doesn't want people not to buy
it because of the issues it's having
because I'm like I feel like us as
Gamers sometimes we gotta we gotta we
gotta come to like a middle ground with
people it's just like when it what I I
think you know the hellblades the
cholesterol protocols those double A
games that could be a AAA if they're
funded correctly next time right we got
to support those even if we're not
seeing too much on it because
it's the difference between us actually
getting a solid product next time or
that franchise I just never seen a lot
of day ever again exactly and you have
we gotta we gotta show love to the new
IP like you know we're getting a lot of
them they're sending over the money the
market and raising 150
157 toys
I'm not supporting sabotage
anyway Betsy you gonna support the death
animations of the Season fans I'm just
joking
oh yeah we didn't even talk about that
but don't do that don't go another whole
uh we don't want to talk about that
Louis song where can I find people find
you what you got going on Sir let me get
these two super cats
trying five dollars Super Chat love
Street Fighter grew up in the arcades in
Puerto Rico oh you're rocking and Neo
Geo two Samurai Showdown one baby yes
yes bought a new arcade stick with sanwa
components let's go gold components
okay talk then we have sir duck number
for 28 months great so great show
enjoying Santa King though okay okay
he's a joy kick no doubt yeah
you could find me dusting off the place
on my shelf where my trophy is gonna go
next week
next week crying your lord returns we
going we gotta review everything see
what happens actually you know I'm a
little nervous about this year it's some
weird categories
[Music]
okay now that's gonna be fire lord King
where can I find people find you what
you got going on Sir well um you can
find me constantly
trying to get back these knees
boy as soon as we get you into some
anesthesia
don't be threatening my bed like this
baby
I got the power chainsaw you ready you
just waiting for them to slip up you
just want one minute
you'll be crazy he takes all he talks
all this and I end up taking another set
of memes
you too scared to take me you lucked up
into the knees
he's on a mission all I needed was one
week
but it's okay though thank God can you
catch me on Twitter yeah roasting these
Foods
yo I saw the other day
the other day a general popped his head
out the bushes to to at me you know
because these dudes I I don't slayed and
filleted them and threw them inside to
cook it in the bushes that's why I said
I was gonna stop selling those bushy
shirts because I didn't threw so many
bodies in the bushes I gotta get rid of
the evidence
so one dude popped his head I was like I
ain't dead yet he's like your king from
your knowledge that everybody every new
household every new PlayStation is a new
sale and uh only reoccurring Xbox dudes
are buying that same Xbox is over and
over again
uh how is that true using your knowledge
I said that's a question for you you
know your boss Jim Ryan he told you you
wasn't enough
um don't come for me unless I say you're
back in the bush you got time to play
with people I got I got time for these
things all day so I look forward to them
like I look forward to oh no with the
Lord absolutely amazing 5 p.m slow
acting a fool talking about these movies
right now we got bullet train coming up
and um we're looking at some stuff on
Netflix we we getting the outline of the
show talking about entertainment stuff
that's going on I know guys wanted us to
go a little bit further into the Chris
Hemsworth stuff I do apologize it was a
flea-flowing uh uh moment attic and I
only did a half an hour last show we we
promised to give you 45 minutes of at
least straight show and that's about it
uh if not a little bit more just set it
small we're not trying to overwork each
other
we're just trying to give you uh some of
the stuff that we're looking at and
watching and I got to watch Attack on
Titan so as attic feels about vampire
Survivor and how he feels about midnight
Sons is how I feel about Attack on Titan
I ain't even playing
I Gotta drag my my tail my sorry tail
over there to finish these butt naked
in a room don't they like butt naked
butt naked Ken dolls right the Ken dolls
yeah yeah these dudes is out there I
would be angry too I if I was a a
40-foot giant with no genitalia
the thing is though is you you only
watch two episodes so far like yes like
the the show really does open up like
drastically okay and the only pushback
I'm gonna give you is when you told me
to watch Naruto from the first first
moment the first episode boy it was hot
like when I watched uh uh to Shin King
uh kensei yeah tournaments first episode
boys hook when I walk Bucky
first episode boys hook
told me yo this is the best thing to
slice bread this this dude right here
this dude
he he out here changing lives making
babies cry I'm like worm so I jumped up
and I was like this dude ain't all that
you're not feeling it yet this dude
right here wait a second let him get
warmed up sometimes you don't get a
chance to make a first impression you
know so the first impression kind of
weak but I'm gonna finish it because I
set up a man of my work I feel that let
me do it you show me the greatest anime
franchise I've ever
been a part of and I've been so
appreciative to you because of that my
kids run with their arms behind their
back because of you
so I gotta respect your opinion and I
just got to stay focused and and love
the process
yeah I was gonna say something I was
gonna say we we need a we need a full
re-watch of Legends of the overview
oh no we can we can do it for the for
the for the patreon yeah that's
something different that is different
look man split everybody in the chat and
get a good show fun topics everybody
came through a lot of love next week
again just for heads up we're gonna do
that that game awards we have a guess
but we still want to do the game Wars
recap Crown your lord the traditional
thing that we do what's up that again
next week our podcast next week's going
to be different than it normally is uh
we we're going to have like a
celebration for the whole year
the only way that we will abandon that
is there's some crazy news that no one
comes out that we cannot.com
I I um I don't know if you guys are
doing it are you guys live reacting to
this yeah yeah we're doing
okay
yeah I'll be there all right I got it I
got it
do you I don't know how you feel about
it because I was going to do a live
interaction where it will show on the
the uh
the screen it was so uh who's winning
how many points we have so yeah I'm
gonna put on my my steam deck where it
goes up a tally every time I do it so
like pretty much like if you do it are
you going to be able to do it it's
Thursday eight nine probably all right
I may be able to phone like phone in and
talk a little bit but that's about it
maybe so uh just send me the updated uh
word press right and then as we go
through I will look at it and I will
update who gets what I just don't know
do you want me to do that or do you want
to like save the surprise you who won to
the actual show no it doesn't matter
because most of the time like it'll be
just me tallying afterwards and then
coming back the following week with the
tally so if it happens live that's
perfect that's what that's okay all
right no doubt that's it
yeah that's it yeah look everybody enjoy
your Sunday another fun one in the round
we'll see y'all next week we are out of
here
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign